Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
Musik
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So, ich bin am Start.
Ich muss selbst erstmal aufwachen.
Okay.
Monk HS.
Das ist ein leises Emote.
Hab ich die Woche irgendwas Spannendes verpasst?
Irgendwas Spannendes.
Nur mehr AI-Slob-News.
Ja gut, das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein.
Ich überlege gerade,
ob es irgendwas Lustiges zu erzählen gibt oder so.
Was die letzten Tage passiert ist.
Mir fällt gerade nichts ein.
Gab es auf der Arbeit irgendwas Lustiges, wo
wieder irgendwie einer komische Dinger wollte oder so?
Ich glaube jetzt nicht.
Dan2Rocks, danke schön für den Sub.
63 Monate.
Boah, krasser Scheiß, Alter.
Massive
Subscription.
Huge.
Speedrun
Ey, ich hab, das hast du bestimmt
Das hast du bestimmt auch gesehen
Es gibt nen
Das geht ein bisschen lang, das können wir uns nicht im Stream angucken
Ich glaub, das ist für die meisten auch nicht so interessant
Aber es gibt nen, seit zwei Wochen oder so
Gibt es einen neuen 120 Sterne Mario 64
Tass
Alter
Das ist so abgedreht, ey
Das hast du bestimmt auch geguckt, oder?
Totoruns, der hat eh jeder, der sich ein bisschen auch nur dafür interessiert, wahrscheinlich geguckt.
Wir machen hier schon mal Mini-PC an.
Zack. Fullscreen.
ja doch
gibt eine sache auf der arbeit vielleicht vielleicht mal erzählen da habe ich schon
ein paar mal erzählt ich arbeite an einer ich arbeite mit an einer internen
und nicht nur es aktuell intern aber das wird auch zum austausch mit anderen
internen block chain plattform seit ein paar jahren und da ist ihnen jetzt
aufgefallen dass das ja komplett angreifbar ist wenn die admins dieser
plattform sich einig sind so also wenn wenn wenn wir uns als admins einig sind
könnten wir uns da irgendwie super viel Krypto-Kram überweisen, weil wir haben ja Admin-Rechte auf alles.
Und da kam letztens die Diskussion auf, ja wie können wir das denn vermeiden?
Habe ich dann auch gemeint, naja gut, wir haben Admin-Zugriff, also sprich alles, was wir jetzt einstellen,
könnten wir auch wieder rückgängig machen.
Also eigentlich können wir da gar nichts dagegen machen.
Da müsst ihr uns einfach ordentlich bezahlen.
Das ist, wenn ich auf blöde Ideen komme.
Weil ansonsten, was willst du machen?
Du hast Admin-Zugriff.
Egal, was du da für Schutzmaßnahmen einführst,
dass du irgendwo nicht drauf connecten darfst
oder irgendwas nicht machen darfst,
ist letztendlich egal,
weil du kannst eh alles wieder rückgängig machen.
Was willst du machen?
Das gibt es noch?
Das benutzt noch jemand?
Ach ja, das habe ich noch gar nicht gesehen.
Ich hab den auf YouTube angeguckt.
Ich hab den nicht.
SGDQ gucke ich schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr.
Vielleicht kann man das mittlerweile wieder gucken.
Zwischenzeitlich
konnte ich mir das nicht mehr geben.
Mittlerweile ist es, glaube ich, wieder ganz okay.
Ich habe aber so gut wie nichts geguckt.
Nee, nee, das gab es sogar auf YouTube,
bevor es bei SGDQ kam.
Ich wollte euch doch 64 gibt, DDR5.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Wenn ich Milliardär bin, wollte ich das machen.
Und nachdem ich noch nicht Milliardär bin, gibt es auch keinen 64 GB DDR5 RAM.
Aber ist jetzt die Chance, ist es gerade billiger geworden oder was?
Oder wie darf ich das interpretieren?
Ach, das meinst du?
Tja.
Ich bin vertrauenswürdig, Admin. Ich nutze die Rechte nicht aus.
Okay, den habe ich tatsächlich ein bisschen geguckt, den, ähm, jetzt ist es Germanj heißt
das, ne?
Oder Germanj, oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht, der Restream, ja, den kann man
sich tatsächlich ganz gut angucken.
Also wie gesagt, Soulstack
Würde mich mal interessieren, Calimero
Ist das bei euch Thema?
Habt ihr das schon eine Weile und wollt das einfach
Jetzt erweitern?
Oder warum fragst du?
Oder überlegt ihr euch ernsthaft, das jetzt neu einzuführen?
Also neu einzuführen würde ich tatsächlich
Davon abraten, weil Ansible ist die einzige Lösung
Die sich da breiter Fläche durchgesetzt hat
Es gab früher noch verschiedene andere Dinge, es gab früher noch Puppet, es gab Chef, es gab Soulstack, aber mittlerweile ist das mit Abstand verbreitetste und da wo du auch Leute für findest, Ansible.
Sonst nix.
Also, wer es nicht kennt, Soulstack ist im Prinzip was in der Richtung wie Ansible.
12 Stunden Bahnfahrt und nur 10 Minuten Verspätung
Ja das kannst du dir jetzt aber mal ganz
Groß im Kalender anstreichen
Das wird nie wieder vorkommen
BlackHD, Dankeschön für den
Submassive Subscriptions
Was müssen wir erstmal Updates machen?
Wichtig. Haben wir schon eine Woche oder so.
Oh je, was ist hier los?
Moment, was will er?
Is newer than extra?
Local is newer than extra?
Gab es da irgendeinen Bug oder so?
Bin ich infiziert mit Supply Chain Dingern oder was?
Wie?
Da müssen wir jetzt googeln, was da los ist.
Pipewire
Warum wir das MonkADB nicht haben?
Echt, was haben wir denn für ein...
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass wir MonkADB
Im Discord haben
Ach, du meinst das hier
Ach, du meinst das hier, Moment, Moment, Moment
Du meinst...
Wo hab ich's denn?
Ey, wenn meine Suche jetzt...
Du meinst das da
Ja, wenn man das ganz klein macht als Emote, dann sieht das doch dann nichts mehr aus, oder?
Guck mal.
Guck mal, das in Emote-Größe, das erkennt man doch gar nicht mehr.
Oder geht das?
Okay, und was mach ich da jetzt?
Was mach ich da jetzt, wenn ich lokal schon ein neueres Pipewire hab, als in extra drin ist?
Nix.
Okay, Bär, mal einfach Update.
Oh, hier gibt es auch massig Updates.
Das wird jetzt das erste Mal komplett die CPU auslasten.
Hier oben, könnt ihr schon gucken.
Huge Update-Org hier am Start.
Mal kurz was trinken.
Hier die B-Lego, genau, umgedreht.
Das kennt ihr wahrscheinlich alle, oder?
wie das DB-Logo
auf dem Kopf aussieht.
Genau so guckst du,
wenn du mit der Bahn fährst.
So, das wird jetzt ein bisschen dauern,
mit den Updates. Guck mal hier.
Komplette Auslastung.
Nur durch Updates. Hier Jetbrain.
Oh, es laggt auch übelst krass rum.
Ich scrolle und es dauert
zwei Sekunden, bis es wirklich scrollt.
Komplett ausgelastet. Gut, ich hab
auch nicht sonderlich viel RAM, muss man dazu sagen.
Also...
Doch, aber ich hab nur
8 GB RAM, aber das juckt es
überhaupt nicht gerade. Boah, seht ihr, wie das
laggt?
Guck mal, ich drück jetzt den
Knopf und jetzt lass ich los.
Das ist hardcore am Lägen.
Die Leute, ohne Scheiß,
die Bahn ist schon abfuck genug.
Aber die Leute in der Bahn, ey, meine
Fresse. Am besten
sind auch die, die immer mit Lautsprecher telefonieren
und sich trotzdem ans Ohr halten.
Wo man sich dann fragt, ja habt ihr nicht gecheckt,
wie so ein Telefon
funktioniert?
Man muss es nicht laut stellen und sich ans Ohr halten
Das ist nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache
Kennt ihr die Leute, die die Handys dann so gekippt am Ohr haben
Anstatt hochkant
So gekippt am Ohr und auf laut stehendes Richtung
Und was mich auch die letzte Zeit
Übertrieben abfuckt ist
Dass wieder so viel Gebettel im Zug unterwegs ist
Der neueste Trend ist
Ja, das, das, der neueste Trend ist jetzt, vielleicht habt ihr, das können wir mal in Chat schreiben, aber das auch schon mal gehabt habt
Wenn du in Frankfurt im Bahnhof sitzt, sitzt schon im Zug, Zug fährt erst in 5 oder 10 Minuten ab
Ja, manchmal kommt das ja vor, dass die Züge schon ein bisschen vor da sind
Dann steigt dann irgendeiner ein, läuft durch das Abteil durch, durch den Waggon durch
Und legt dir einen kleinen Zettel drauf, ja, auf diesem Zettel steht dann irgendwie sowas
wie, ich bin, keine Ahnung,
ich bin so arm und brauche
Hilfe, bitte spenden oder
Gott segne sie, steht da meistens
noch irgendwie sowas drauf.
Gott segne sie, bitte spenden oder sowas in der Richtung.
Da legen die dir irgendwelche Zettel hin
und witzigerweise, was ich halt
gar nicht checke, eine Packung
Tempotaschentücher,
warum auch immer,
keine Ahnung.
Und da legen die das dann drauf, diesen Zettel
und dann
laufen die nach 5 Minuten wieder durch
und sammeln das ein.
In der Hoffnung, du spendest ihnen.
So.
Das muss ich ja sagen, das ist
schon abfuck genug, aber das geht ja noch.
Die belästigen dich wenigstens nicht, ja?
Die nehmen das und... Aber in letzter Zeit...
Weil wenn du das nimmst, wollen sie
Geld von dir. Ach, so ist das!
Du meinst, wenn du dir ein Tempotaschentuch nimmst,
wollen sie Geld von dir. Da könnten die mich mal gerne haben.
Das ist wie dieser Scam.
letztens ein Video gesehen, wobei das Video
auch schon ein bisschen
sehr effekthascherig
war. Da habe ich letztens ein Video
gesehen, dass wenn du in Paris unterwegs
bist, oder war es
oder war es Florenz?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Ich glaube Paris
war es, wo die dir
irgendwelche Armbändchen
ans Handgelenk machen und sagen, Geschenk,
Geschenk, Geschenk. Und wenn du dann weiter
gehst, wollen sie Geld für das Armband und so.
Vielleicht ist es
ja ähnlicher ähnlicher trick zumindest die die werfen mich gar nicht so sehr
aber in letzter zeit laufen immer mehr leute durch den zug die dir sagen
entschuldigung entschuldigung da guckst du an bitte spenden bitte spenden
das geht mir so auf den sack
Spanien wollten sie in ihrer Packung Taschentücher verkaufen.
Geile Taktik.
Können sie sich ein Prime Sub kaufen.
BlackHD,
Dankeschön für den Sub, falls ich ihn nicht gesehen habe.
MonkeS, falls du das meinst.
So.
Oh, guck mal.
Wir haben fertig Updates gemacht.
Es ist hier auch wirklich alles durch.
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Leute, Leute, kann ich mich trauen?
Kann ich mich trauen,
hier zu updaten?
Art User Repos zu updaten oder werde ich dann sofort Supply Chain Attacked?
Ich trau mich nicht.
MonkaS.
Der Snapshot automatisch, Nico.
Der Snapshot ist automatisch, wenn ich Updates mache.
Guck, der hat hier auch gesnapshottet.
Ne, ne, ich reboote nur.
Moment, war überhaupt Kernel Update dabei?
Muss ich überhaupt rebooten?
Ja, ja, Kernel Update.
Okay, ja, ja.
Also.
Reboot.
Wenn ich Tastatur umstöpseln,
dass ich Passwort eingeben kann.
Letztens habe ich auf Reddit
einen Post gelesen, da hat sich
einer voll empört,
dass in Frankfurt keiner
den Leuten hilft, wenn sie auf der Straße liegen.
So, die hat dann quasi geschrieben
Ähm
Ich krieg das gar nicht mehr zusammen
Sie war in Frankfurt und da lag jemand
Auf dem Boden, der offensichtlich Hilfe brauchte
Und keiner hat sich dafür interessiert
Und sie hat dann irgendwie
Versucht den Nonas zu rufen oder sonst was
Ich weiß nicht mehr
Das Ding ist halt
Ich kann verstehen, dass das etwas befremdlich wirkt
Wenn du nicht oft in Frankfurt bist
Das Ding ist nur, du müsstest eigentlich am Tag, also wenn es danach geht, dass irgendwelche random Leute hilfebedürftig auf dem Boden liegen in Frankfurt,
dann müsstest du eigentlich jeden Tag zweimal auf dem Hinweg zu arbeiten, zweimal auf dem Rückweg zu arbeiten, die Polizei oder den Notarzt rufen.
Gerade wenn du zum Hauptbahnhof läufst, das ist eigentlich normal, dass da Leute rumliegen, die so aussehen, als brauchen sie Hilfe.
Ja, wahrscheinlich brauchen die auch Hilfe, aber wahrscheinlich wollen die auch keine, könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Also, das ist, ja, ich verstehe, dass das jemand, der nicht oft in der Ecke ist, befremdlich wirkt.
Aber du wärst ja mit nichts anderem beschäftigt, als Sonars rufen in Frankfurt.
So, haben wir jetzt eigentlich alles?
Pass auf, gibt es wieder ein neues Update.
Bam.
Ne.
Außer Pipewire, was neuer ist lokal als im Repo.
Wie auch immer ich es überhaupt installiert habe, wenn es neuer als im Repo ist.
Warst du schon mal beim Helter Steine in Frankfurt?
Ne.
Aber ich hab den Helter Steil tatsächlich schon mal gesehen unterwegs.
Aber in dem Laden war ich noch nicht.
Hat der neue RTL-Treiber das Problem gefixt?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab's noch nicht ausprobiert.
Das müssen wir unbedingt machen.
Netzwerkkartenkrempel.
Oh, guck mal.
Ich hab's sogar hier noch aufgeschrieben.
Aber das ist ja eher Ride-Only, die Liste.
Das muss man unbedingt ausprobieren, ob der neue Treiber meine Netzwerkkartenprobleme unter Linux fixt.
Was ich viel nicer finden würde, ehrlich gesagt, wenn die mal ihren Kerneldreiber updaten würden.
Weil das ist halt ein kompletter Witz gewesen.
Warte mal, ich versuche euch das mal zu zeigen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das jetzt finde.
Aber wir gucken mal.
Ich habe doch hier Linux.
Wir müssen mal kurz gucken.
Wo ist dieser Krempel hier drin?
Drivers?
Ne, nicht Aquanet. Ethernet?
Realtek?
Air?
Ja, lass uns mal kurz in das Kernel-Loch gucken.
2026.
Das Ding ist,
der Treiber
hier drinnen im Kernel ist halt
G-Bait.
Das ist kein, also
man könnte sagen,
ja, das ist ein Treiber
im Linux-Kernel, der ist ja auch Open Source.
Das Problem ist, das ist
zwar streng genommen ein Open Source
Treiber, aber
genau hingeguckt, ist das
wieder kein Open Source Treiber.
Obwohl das Source Code open ist.
Ich versuche euch das mal kurz zu zeigen.
Weil
dieser Treiber
zum größten Teil
Ich finde jetzt leider, dass das Comet
nicht. Ja, weil der Treiber
zum größten Teil
aus Binary geschwubbelt
besteht.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das ist.
Ja, guck hier. Das ist der Treiber.
Also du hast eigentlich gar keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Wenn du jetzt sagen würdest,
ey, guck mal, ich hab zum Beispiel
das Problem, dass
das Ding in der VM so lahm ist.
Du hast keine Chance, weil du weißt
nicht, was das macht. Das ist komplett
Magic. Also ja, das ist ein
Open-Source-Treiber, aber ihr habt
trotzdem absolut keine Chance zu checken, was der
eigentlich macht und was das bedeutet.
Es sind ja auch nicht wirklich Comments großartig
drin, dass du das was wüsstest.
Na gut, hier doch zumindest. Also das sind einfach
Magic Bytes.
Ja? Ohne
irgendwelche Hinweise drauf, was das
machen. Ja, letztendlich, viele Treiber
sind ja letztendlich irgendwie Magic Bytes
an irgendwelche Hardware-Adressen, okay.
Aber da ist halt nichts. Das ist einfach ein riesen
Commit gewesen, was
Magic Values an Magic Adressen
schreibt.
Du hast wirklich absolut
keine Chance hier irgendwie jemals was
selbst zu fixen. Das muss Realtek machen.
Und Realtek
hat keinen Bock.
Das letzte Treiber-Update ist glaube ich
von vor vier Monaten. Und das
einzige, was sich da geändert hat an dem Realtek-Treiber
ist,
dass sie gefixt haben,
dass das Ding beim Reboot ab und zu kaputt geht.
Muss man sich auch mal vorstellen. Ein Reboot macht
die Netzwerkkarte kaputt. So, das heißt, hier bleibt
eigentlich nichts anderes übrig wie den offiziellen realtec treiber zu verwenden
wenn du wenn du probleme hast problem ist halt ist kein kölner treiber das heißt du
musst dir in den dk ms bild raussuchen was bei jedem kölner update den treiber
neu baut und sowas ist halt vom handling ja auch ein bisschen eklig und wie das
bei box mox versions updates komplett ist keine ahnung ob da das ganze dk ms
Zeug überhaupt greift.
Das ist halt ziemlicher Sack.
Ja, mal gespannt, was ChatGPT
oder Fable oder
Mythos und was auch immer da machen würde.
Ich meine, die können ja auch nicht in Magic Bytes
reininterpretieren, was das ist.
Die können irgendwas zusammen halluzinieren.
Ob das dann was bringt, ist fraglich.
Was ist denn
Erdhase?
Erdhase.h
Erdtase
Realtek Automotiv Switch
Okay, das ist irgendwas anderes
Erdtase
Ja, und da hat sich leider nichts getan
Aber es gibt jetzt übrigens
Das ist eine mega hässliche Webseite
By the way, hier haben wir es sogar noch auf
Also keine Ahnung, wer bei Realtek
Diese Webseite gebaut hat, ne
Die Webseite
Sieht halt einfach aus wie 1998
Ungefähr
Aber bis auf das
Bis auf dieses komische Hamburger Menü
Und die Slide Animation
Die sieht halbwegs aktuell aus
Übrigens das ist auch ziemlich
Billig gemacht hier
Aber egal
Zumindest gibt es hier eine neue
Ich muss mal kurz refreshen
DOS
Alter
Zumindest gibt es hier eine neue 3-Ball-Version.
Vom 16.
Ne, hier da.
Vom 3.7.
Die wollte ich mal ausprobieren.
Wir haben es ja mittlerweile hingekriegt,
dass die Sache ganz okay funktioniert unter Linux.
Aber so die Peak-Performance hat das Ding immer noch nicht.
Also so eine 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte sollte so 9,5 oder so hinkriegen.
Aber die kriegt teilweise nur 8,6
Und sowas hin
Das ist schon mies
Ich meine das ist jetzt nicht so als
Würdest du eine Riesen-Normaschine machen
Aber es wäre schon nice wenn du 10 Gigs
In einer 2 Karte auch 10 Gigs machst
Tempel OS
Ja ganz bestimmt
Ganz bestimmt
Guck mal es gibt für Novell
Boah, da hätte ich jetzt richtig Bock drauf
Leute, ich hab wieder abgenommen
Ich hab wieder abgenommen
Ich wiege jetzt wieder
35, äh 35
Alter
Ich hatte ja schon mal ganz knapp unter 80
vor einem Jahr oder eineinhalb Jahren
oder so, oder vor zwei Jahren, vor zwei Jahren
ungefähr, würde ich mal sagen.
Hatte ich so um die 80.
Hat ein bisschen
geschwankt, knapp unter 80, 81.
Und dann habe ich ja
zwei große Pausen, was Training
angeht, gemacht.
Bei welcher Größe? 1,74.
Dann habe ich ja zwei große
Pausen, was Training und so angeht,
gemacht. Wegen hier
psychischer Probleme, habe ich ja schon öfters
mal erzählt und jetzt seit ein paar monaten wird ja wieder regelmäßig
trainiert also regelmäßig heißt wirklich jeden tag nur pause also der einzige
tag wo ich nicht trainiere ist wenn mein trainingsplan sagt rest oder ich mache
oder oder recovery recovery drin steht dann mache ich halt 30 minuten super
langsam und sowas und seitdem habe ich wieder abgenommen ich will jetzt nur
85, irgendwas.
Also ich bin wieder runter
von...
Ich glaube, das Höchste, was ich mal hatte, war
88 wieder.
Aber da war ich auch komplett voll gefressen
nach dem Teambuilding-Event.
Jetzt habe ich wieder 85,
85 oder so.
Also es geht runter.
Es ist jetzt innerhalb vom
letzten Monat
1,5 Kilo schon wieder runtergegangen.
Also es macht schon was aus, dass man regelmäßig trainiert und was auch was ausmacht, nicht mal ganz so viel Scheiße fressen.
Also was ich jetzt probiere ist, ich habe schon ein paar mal, welche App? Die Garmin App. Garmin Connect.
Ich habe ja schon ein paar mal erzählt, ihr wisst ja wie das ist, Veganer erzählen immer, dass sie Veganer sind, aber ich bin kein Veganer.
Ich esse aber in letzter Zeit vermehrt veganische Gerichte.
Ich ernähre mich nicht komplett vegan, habe ich auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Also ich futter immer noch ab und zu mal Hähnchen oder irgendwelche Wurstsalat-Dinger oder sonst was.
Und ich mache das auch, ehrlich gesagt, nicht primär wegen dem Tierwohl, sondern weil es einfach ungesund ist, zu viel Fleisch zu fressen.
Ja, ich habe aber doch die Garmin-Uhr wieder.
Also nicht die aus dem Fluss, sondern eine neue.
Das habe ich doch im gleichen Video erzählt.
Wo ich auch erzählt habe, dass ich die in den Main geschmissen habe.
Anstellungsuser, ja.
Naja, zumindest habe ich das jetzt so.
Bei mir auf der Arbeit mache ich das jetzt immer so zum Mittagessen.
Weil da habe ich halt früher immer richtig reingehauen, ja.
So großer Salat, große Pizza und volle Pulle reingeschaufelt und so.
Also mittlerweile mache ich das so, ich hole mir so einen halben, halbe Salatschüssel und ein veganes Gericht, falls es da was gibt.
Also was halbwegs schmeckt.
In der Regel haben die da vegane Sachen, die ganz okay sind.
Am Freitag beispielsweise, oder nee, oder wann war das? Ich weiß gar nicht, was es war.
Da gab es, ähm, was war das? Rote Beete oder sowas.
Da habe ich auf die Speisekarte geguckt und habe mir gedacht, so.
Ich hab's dann aber ausprobiert und es hat gar nicht schlecht geschmeckt.
Das war so, war irgendwie frittierte rote Beete oder sowas.
Keine Ahnung.
Hätte ich nie gedacht, dass es schmeckt.
Das hab ich mir vorhin angeguckt und hab schon halben Kotzreflex gehabt, als ich das gelesen hab.
Aber dann hab ich's ausprobiert und hab mir gedacht, ey, das schmeckt da eigentlich ganz gut.
Das hat so gut geschmeckt, dass ich mir gedacht hab, das könnte man auch mal daheim machen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich futter immer noch
Ich futter immer noch ab und zu Fleisch
Werde ich wahrscheinlich auch beibehalten
Weil ich hab auch gar keinen Bock, mich mit irgendwie
Großartigen Ernährungssachen zu beschäftigen
Dass man da auch alles kriegt, was man braucht
Und so, kein Bock
Ich futter ab und zu ein bisschen Wurstsalat, ein bisschen Hähnchen
Und so, das hab ich von allem genug
Ich futter halt nicht mehr jeden Tag
Fleisch und jetzt auch nicht mehr in so großen Mengen
Naja
Und seitdem ich das mache
Seitdem ich mittags quasi
nur noch einen halben Salat, eine halbe Schüssel
Salatfuttere, plus ein veganes
Gericht mittags, außer halt ab und zu mal
was, ja, Fischfutter ich beispielsweise
auch ganz gern und ab und zu
hol ich mir mal eine Pizza oder sowas, ja,
seitdem ich das mache und abends ein bisschen
weniger esse und jetzt halt wieder regelmäßig trainieren
gehe, geht es halt wieder steil runter,
wie gesagt, letzten Monat ungefähr, was
ja, knapp eineinhalb Kilo weniger,
ja, das ist immer, am Anfang geht es
schneller, aber ich bin zuversichtlich,
ich bin zuversichtlich,
dass das wieder in Richtung 80 Kilo geht jetzt.
So.
Ich muss mal kurz mein Handy holen.
Ich muss das neben mich legen.
Weil heute auf der Arbeit sind irgendwelche Umstellungen an irgendwelchen Netzwerk...
...Crosswitches oder so, keine Ahnung.
Und es könnte sein, dass irgendwas kaputt geht, wo die Unterstützung aus dem Linux-Umfeld braucht.
Das heißt, heute ist wieder passives Einkommen, was generiert wird.
Und das ist nicht schlecht, Leute.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht.
Also in der Regel ist bei uns bei solchen Wartungsarbeiten passiert gar nichts.
Wenn was passiert, musst du halt ran.
Aber wenn nichts passiert, was zu 95% der Fälle der Fall ist,
verdienst du halt einfach mal für Samstag und Sonntag,
gut Samstag war jetzt nicht Sonntag,
verdienst du halt 400 Euro oder so.
Durch nichts tun.
Kann man sich nicht beschweren, oder?
Hast du den neuen IT-Campus von Lidl schon gesehen?
Nee.
Kannst du Remote viel machen oder musst du dann raus?
Ich kann alles Remote machen.
Es sei denn, dass sowohl VPN als auch Citrix nicht mehr gehen würden.
Dann müsste ich nach Frankfurt fahren.
Zugang zum Rechenzentrum habe ich eh nicht.
Da sind die super restriktiv.
Da darf eigentlich so gut wie keiner rein bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber.
Ich vermisse das ja schon ein bisschen.
Ich habe es ja schon öfters gesagt.
Also, falls jemand ein Rechenzentrum in Frankfurt hat und da ein paar Server einbauen möchte,
ich mache das auch kostenlos.
Ich hätte mal wieder Bock, ein bisschen im Rechenzentrum rumzubasteln.
Wir benutzen Schritttricks, ja.
Ich meine, mir ist klar, dass das nicht geht.
Allein schon aus versicherungstechnischen Gründen.
Ja, geht jetzt nicht, aber ich würde es trotzdem machen.
Wir benutzen Chitrix.
Ganz, ganz viel Chitrix benutzen wir.
Guckt, ich habe ja auch hier Chitrix, Chitrix Workspace installiert bei mir auf dem Rechner, damit ich mich connectoren kann.
Ich muss aber sagen, so schlimm ist das gar nicht.
Das ist schon ganz okay.
Also, der Trade-Off ist ja, ich habe zwei Möglichkeiten, remote zu arbeiten.
Ich kann entweder das Notebook von der Arbeit nehmen, dann verbindet er sich da quasi mit sowas wie VPN in die Arbeit und ich kann direkt mit dem Notebook arbeiten.
Ah, okay.
Oder ich logge mich über Citrix ein, hier vom Desktop und habe dann eine VM, auf der ich arbeite.
So, das Ding ist jetzt nur, ich hasse es am Notebook zu arbeiten und ich habe keinen Bock irgendwie Tastatur, Maus, Monitore, was auch immer, daheim umzustöpseln.
Das heißt, der Trade-Off ist, ein bisschen weniger Input-Lag auf dem Notebook versus ich kann am Desktop sitzen bleiben und meine Tastatur, meine Maus und meinen Monitor verwenden.
dann nehme ich das bisschen lag von Zytrix in Kauf und habe lieber mein komplettes Setup an meinem Schreibtisch mit allem, wie halt so ist.
Dazu kommt, es gibt bei uns zwei Möglichkeiten, wie du Zytrix verwenden kannst.
Es gibt einmal so eine Terminal Server VM, die ist ziemlich schwach dimensioniert und laggy as fuck,
aber es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, wenn der Chef das genehmigt und mein Chef genehmigt sowas immer instant,
Bam, dass man eine
Dedicated VM kriegt
Wo man dann
Quasi auswählen kann, was die
Für Kerne und RAM und sonst was haben
Soll, und da habe ich
8 Kerne und ich glaube 16 Ggramm
Die flutscht
Ganz gut, und was noch viel geiler
Ist, die hat eine Grafikkarte
Die haben irgendwie, ich habe
Keine Ahnung, wie die das gemacht haben
Wahrscheinlich ist das, also das ist auf VMware Basis
Wahrscheinlich haben die VMware
Wie heißen diese, wie heißen die
Tesla? Ne. Wie heißen die Dinger von Nvidia, die für Virtualisierung sind?
Es gibt von Nvidia Grafikkarten, die sind für Virtualisierung gedacht.
Die kannst du quasi aufsplitten. Da kannst du aus einer Grafikkarte 16 Grafikkarten machen.
Virtuell und sowas.
Per SAEOV, glaube ich. Crit könnte sein, dass die so heißen.
Wahrscheinlich haben die da sowas drin.
Du hast quasi wirklich eine echte Grafikkarte in der VM, ordentlich CPU und ordentlich RAM.
Also das ist dann in Zytrix echt erträglich, ja.
Ja gut, was ist die Alternative, ne?
Meine beste Alternative, die, also am liebsten, ja, am liebsten hätte ich ja die Möglichkeit,
einfach vom Desktop mich per VPN zu verbinden und dann auf meine Linux-Kiste von dort.
Von daheim, ja.
Weil dann würde ich einfach hier von einer ordentlichen Linux-Kiste, Linux-VM, per SSH auf meine Admin-Kiste daheim und da alles machen.
Das geht ja leider nicht.
Das wäre natürlich richtig nice, aber das geht ja nicht.
Das wäre exzellent, sozusagen.
Ich habe auch schon versucht, ein bisschen zu tricksen mit SSH-Tunneln.
So nach dem Motto, kann ich nicht vor meinem Notebook einen SSH-Tunnel auf eine lokale VM bei mir im Netzwerk aufbauen und mich dann mit VPN verbinden, um dann über den SSH-Tunnel irgendwie...
Geht alles nicht, das haben die alles geblockt, keine Chance.
No chance.
Kannst nichts machen.
Sackt. Aber gut.
Gut, das geilste
ist Zytrix jetzt nicht.
Wie gesagt, wenn man ein ordentliches VPN
hätte, wo man dann per SSH direkt an seine
Linux-Admin-Kiste kommt, wäre
natürlich noch viel, viel besser.
Da hättest du keinen Input-Lag mehr und sonst
was. Aber geht leider nicht.
Und
und anbetrachtet der Tatsache, dass das nicht geht,
ist, glaube ich, Zytrix noch das kleinere Übel.
Weil was willst du sonst großartig machen?
Was gibt's? Chat,
wirklich eine ernst gemeinte Frage.
Vielleicht kennt sich ja jemand aus von euch.
Was wäre eure Alternative zu Zytrix?
Wenn ihr euch was aussuchen könntet.
Gibt's da überhaupt irgendwas?
So Enterprise mäßig.
Ja, aber Parallels ist doch für Desktop-Virtualisierung und nicht Remote-Zugriff auf 4Ms.
Ich wollte euch übrigens noch was fragen.
Ich komme gerade nicht drauf.
Ich hatte letztens was auf der Arbeit, wo ich mir gedacht habe, Max, da musst du mal den Stream fragen.
Ob euch da irgendwas zu einfällt.
Ah ja, ich weiß es wieder.
Ich weiß es wieder.
Hat sie heute schon gestreichelt?
Ja, die war heute schon am Start.
Oh, ich muss Chatterino starten.
Ich weiß es wieder, Chat.
Also, stellt euch mal vor,
das würde mich wirklich interessieren,
ob ihr da eine gute Idee habt.
Ich erzähle euch dann auch meine Idee, okay?
Was ich mir ausgedacht habe.
Also, stellt euch mal vor,
ihr habt eine Anwendung.
Hier, hier.
Das ist eine App.
Minus, minus, Debug.
So.
Oder, machen wir mal so, okay?
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr habt eine Web-Anwendung, die könnt ihr mit einem Minus-Minus-Debug-Flag starten.
Und das Minus-Minus-Debug-Flag sorgt dafür, dass sie bestimmte Anfragen nicht mehr richtig validiert, sondern einfach durchwinkt.
Oder nennen wir es mal nicht Debug, nennen wir es mal NoValidate.
Anwendung, könnt ihr das setzen.
Das ist wichtig zum Testen, das ist wichtig zum Entwickeln.
Zum Beispiel, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht genau erzählen, stellt euch vor, das wäre was, was gegen PayPal geht oder so.
Und ihr wollt halt auch das Ganze ohne externen Zugriff auf die PayPal-API testen können, also quasi nur das, was ihr lokal habt.
So, und dafür gibt es den Minus-Minus-No-Validate-Parameter, der dann dafür sorgt, dass ihr Anfragen testen könnt, aber es passieren halt keine echten Transaktionen oder so. Ja, das winkt die App einfach nur durch.
So und ihr wollt jetzt sicherstellen, wie würdet ihr das machen? Ihr wollt sicherstellen, dass in Produktion dieser Flag hier niemals oder nicht ohne größeren Aufwand, sagen wir mal, ohne dass es jemand mitbekommt.
Sag mal, ohne dass es jemand mitbekommt. Also in Produktion sollte dieser Fleck gar nicht setzbar sein oder aber er sollte definitiv nicht setzbar sein, ohne dass es jemand mitbekommt.
Woran kennen wir, dass der Server ein Pott ist? Ja, da hast du schon das erste Problem.
Da hast du schon das erste Problem, was ich mich auch gefragt habe, ja.
Hostname, das läuft im Kubernetes Cluster
Du hast in dem Cluster
soweit ich weiß, keine einfache
Möglichkeit rauszufinden
ob du in Prod bist, außer
außer
du könntest irgendwie mit Trick 17
frag mich nicht wie das geht, die Google
api abfragen in welchem projekt du bist ob dann p am anfang ist oder sowas zum beispiel
das läuft im kuba das klasse läuft im kuba das klasse so und environment variablen
lizenz
Lizenzfile.
Das Ding ist aber,
das Ding ist also, okay,
da muss ich euch noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen.
Ja, das
mit, also, das Problem ist,
an sich wäre das einfach.
An sich könntest du sagen,
Environment-Variable
Stage gleich Brot.
Das würde funktionieren.
Aber die wollen ja auch,
dass Admins, so wie ich zum Beispiel, nicht das ohne größeren Aufwand, ohne dass es jemand mitbekommt, ändern können.
Und ich könnte ja jederzeit sowohl das Lizenzfile austauschen, als auch die ConfigMap ändern, die Environment-Variablen ändern oder sonst was.
Ich bin ja Admin auf dem Cluster.
Ihr werdet jetzt natürlich zu Recht sagen, das gleiche was ich auch gesagt habe, du kannst da 100% sicher eigentlich nichts dagegen machen, weil alles was du als Admin einführst, kannst du wieder ausschalten. Aber wie würdet ihr es machen, dass es zumindest auch für einen Admin relativ schwierig ist, beziehungsweise so, dass es auf jeden Fall jemand mitkriegt?
Habt ihr da vielleicht irgendwelche chlorreiche Ideen?
Ich erkläre euch dann auch, was ich mir überlegt habe, okay?
Weil ich finde, ich habe da eine ganz gute Idee
Vielleicht habt ihr ja auch noch welche
Soll das Ding selbst versuchen, ob die PayPal-API erreichen kann?
Das war jetzt ein schlechtes Beispiel
weil da geht es ja gar nicht drum
ganz das habe ich mir auch überlegt das ding macht eine api call gegen
ressourcen die extern ist und vom admin nicht administriert werden kann diese
api car löst eine meldung aus und muss bestätigt werden
So was habe ich mir auch gedacht. Das Ding ist nur, ich könnte den Request ja einfach umbiegen.
Ich könnte den Request einfach umbiegen.
Es müsste höchstens was sein, was über HTTPS geht, wo ich keine Möglichkeit habe, das Zertifikat zu faken oder sowas.
Das ist aber ziemlich schwierig, ehrlich gesagt.
Das müsste dann ein komplett anderes Team machen, zum Beispiel.
Das wäre enormer Verwaltungsaufwand.
Liegt das Diploma nicht in eurem Git?
Doch.
Du kannst zum Aktivieren des Schalters ein Secret verlangen.
Das Secret ist eine Art von Passwortmanager.
oder als Pöckchen. Ja, das muss man.
Ja gut,
wie gibst du das Secret ein?
Die Anwendung muss es ja checken können. Das heißt,
einfach Passwort ist wahrscheinlich schlecht.
Einfaches Passwort kriege ich ja auch raus,
wahrscheinlich, wenn ich das Binary analysiere.
Das müsste dann
irgendeine Zertifikatsgeschichte sein.
So nach dem Motto,
das muss signiert sein.
Das Secret muss quasi
selber, das muss signiert sein
mit einem Key, den ich halt nicht habe.
Ja, also das müsste
quasi, du könntest
irgendwie noch eine Checksumme mitschicken von den Binary
selbst, wenn du das nicht einstößt.
Ah, das ist tatsächlich eine gute Idee.
Checksumme,
Checksumme, ohne Scheiß, das ist eine mega
gute Idee. Das bringt zwar
jetzt nix,
das bringt zwar jetzt
da, aber das macht es nochmal eine ganze
Ecke sicherer, Checksumme.
Also wir könnten tatsächlich prüfen, ob die Anwendung, die dort gestartet wird oder das Image, das kann man bestimmt in Kubernetes, da gibt es bestimmt irgendwas, dass man da sagen kann, hier prüfe die Checksumme oder so.
Dass wir die Checksumme überprüfen, dass das Image das richtige ist.
Ne, bei uns gibt es gerade nichts.
Das ist die letzten Jahre auch total zurückgegangen.
Das Einzige, was wir jetzt gesucht haben in letzter Zeit, war ein Junior Storage Admin.
Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile besetzt.
Das haben wir. Das haben wir. Logging haben wir.
Also, okay. Ich erzähle euch jetzt mal meine Lösung des Ganzen.
Wobei, ich sollte euch vielleicht vorher noch was erzählen, was ich euch noch nicht erzählt habe.
Vielleicht habt ihr da noch eine bessere Idee.
Diese Software, die bekommt Requests regelmäßig.
Das habe ich euch schon gesagt.
Die bekommt regelmäßig Requests.
Und diese Requests, die müssen halt mit einer gültigen Signatur signiert sein.
Damit die Software die verarbeitet.
Okay?
Und das kann man mit Novalidate ausschalten.
Das habe ich euch im Prinzip schon erzählt.
Ihr habt ja das Logging umgesetzt.
Da gibt es auf Projektebene im Google...
Nee, stimmt gar nicht.
Stimmt gar nicht.
Haha.
Das ist tatsächlich was, wo ich nichts machen kann.
Die Logs...
Okay, ey, das ist tatsächlich sogar besser umgesetzt, als ich gedacht habe.
Es gibt einen...
Eine Pipeline, nenne ich es jetzt...
Pipeline ist plötzlich irgendwie so ein Forwarder für bestimmte Logs von Kubernetes nach Splunk.
und
in Splunk gibt es dann
einen Alert, wenn
in dem Log was Spezielles
drin steht. Es gibt zwei Alerts.
Es steht drinnen, wenn in dem Log, es gibt einen Alert,
wenn in dem Log drinnen steht
NoValidate gleich True
und es gibt einen Alert, wenn länger
als, keine Ahnung, fünf Minuten keine
Logs eingetroffen sind.
So, das
gibt's. Natürlich könnte
ich das mit Sicherheit irgendwie,
weil ich admin im Cluster bin, wahrscheinlich könnte ich es irgendwie fixen, das Problem.
Oder faken, ja, irgendwie.
Also es gibt einen Splunk-Alert und es gibt, glaube ich, auch auf Google Cloud Projekt-Ebene einen Alert,
wenn das gesetzt ist.
Das wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich, ja, im Prinzip ist das so was, ja.
Wahrscheinlich könnte ich das im Zweifelsfall, wenn ich sehr kreativ bin, auch manipulieren als Admin.
Wahrscheinlich. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall nicht so einfach.
Also, was ich mir jetzt überlegt habe, ist Folgendes.
Zweistufig.
Könnt ihr mir mal schreiben, was ihr davon haltet.
Als erstes würde ich hardcoded...
Ich würde hardcoded einen 15 Minuten Timeout einführen.
Der läuft immer.
Also, sobald die Anwendung startet und NoValidate gleich True gesetzt ist, passiert für 15 Minuten erstmal gar nichts.
Es bleibt auf False.
Und erst nach 15 Minuten schaltet es sich, wenn es gesetzt ist, auf True.
Das heißt, du hast 15 Minuten, in denen du nichts machen kannst, in denen alle Alerts anspringen können und sagen, ey, guck mal, da hat einer Validate auf True gesetzt.
NoValidate auf True.
Also ein hardcoded 15 Minuten Timeout in der App, wo du nichts dagegen machen kannst.
Also sprich, auch in Tests, ja, auch in Tests, sonst wo, musst du halt 15 Minuten warten, nachdem du die Anwendung gestartet hast.
Hardcoded.
Also das heißt, du hast schon mal 15 Minuten Zeit, dass die Anwendung, dass die Alerts losgehen.
So.
Und das nächste ist, und ich finde, das ist Big Brain, das ist Big Brain Time.
Ich habe doch gesagt, die Anwendung verarbeitet Requests, die normalerweise signiert sein müssen.
Warum macht man da nicht einen initialen signierten Request, der das Validate ausschalten kann?
Wisst ihr, wie ich meine?
Du musst einmal einen gültig signierten Request schicken, der dann der Anwendung sagt, die nächsten Requests müssen nicht mehr validated werden.
so bist du eigentlich komplett safe wenn du die zwei sachen hast du hast 15 minuten timeout und
den ausschalt request kannst du nur schicken wenn die einmalig gültig signiert wurde das heißt das
muss über die normalen wege sowie bei novalidate gleich falls einmal ein signierter request
reinkommen der sagt ab jetzt nicht mehr prüfen aber wenn du die zwei sachen hast du kannst die
Alerts nicht mehr wirklich umgehen und du kannst es
gar nicht ausschalten, ohne dass
mehrere Leute gleichzeitig dieses Ding signiert
haben und abschicken,
dann bist du ja eigentlich safe.
So, und nachdem garantiert unsere
Entwickler mega rumkotzen würden bei dieser
Lösung, weil die wollen ja ihre Software
ordentlich testen können,
müssen die sich halt irgendein Debug-Bild
machen, wo das Hardcoded
auf False steht.
Was haltet
ihr davon also ich glaube ich glaube viel sicherer kann man es nicht mehr machen wenn man will dass
auch administrat nichts ändern dürfen du hast bestimmt irgendwelche schlupflöcher theoretisch
die existieren immer noch ja ich könnte zum beispiel zum beispiel ja zum beispiel ein
schlupfloch wo man sieht dass man es nie komplett aushebeln kann batmans ist ich könnte die app mir
einfach ziehen.
Das ist eine Java-App. Ich könnte die
dekompilieren,
hardcoded, novalidate, gleich false reinschreiben
und die App wieder starten.
Da könnte keiner
was dagegen machen.
Deswegen fand ich die Idee von euch vorhin mit Checksummen
für das Image auch gar nicht schlecht.
Falls man irgendwie noch die Checksumme
überprüfen könnte.
Das wäre nämlich doppelt
Pfeifert. Da könnte ich nicht mal einfach die Anwendung
austauschen und ein neues Image bauen.
Aber selbst den Check könnte ich wahrscheinlich wieder ausschalten, weil ich bin ja Admin in dem Projekt und in dem Cluster.
So, jetzt habe ich mir überlegt, also ich glaube, viel sicherer kriegt man es nicht mehr hin.
Genau, genau, das denke ich mir nämlich auch.
Also das wäre schon wirklich sehr pfeifett, wenn das jemand umgehen könnte.
Also ich glaube, viel sicherer kriegt man es einfach nicht mehr.
Vielleicht verdienen bei uns die Admins deswegen auch so gut.
Dass die nicht anfällig sind für irgendwelche Bestechungsversuche oder irgendwelche krummen Dinger.
Ist ja eigentlich auch sinnvoll, ne?
Wenn die sagen, ne, ihr könnt mir mal gestohlen bleiben.
Oder aber, ihr müsstet mir so viel dafür bezahlen, dass ich daran nur denken würde.
Das wollt ihr nicht bezahlen.
Das ist tatsächlich auch eine Idee, ja.
Aber dann würden wir wahrscheinlich eher
die Anwendung erstmal runterfahren, wenn sowas käme.
Weil besser keine Anwendung
als paar Millionen in Krypto-Sachen weg.
Ja, ja, das ist auch eine gute Idee.
Das ist gut.
Sonst, sonst, sonst,
brutforst sich das noch irgendeiner.
Wobei ich mir das sehr schwierig vorstelle.
Aber Chat, gut, dass wir drüber geredet haben.
Ich habe schon zwei Sachen.
Checksum überprüfen und nur einmal nach dem Request
und dann sich beenden, wenn es falsch ist.
Ja, gute Idee.
Ich habe schon oft gesagt,
Chad, ich bin bestechlich, aber
in dem Beziehung bin ich nicht bestechlich.
Also,
wahrscheinlich könnte mir keiner so viel Geld
bieten, dass ich dort
irgendwelche Dinger manipulieren würde auf der Arbeit.
Das würde ich nicht machen.
Wo ich bestechlich bin, ist,
was ich für Sellout auf Twitch und YouTube
mache.
Wenn da Raid Shadow Legends kommt und sagt,
Max, wir bezahlen dir 5000 Euro oder was auch immer,
dann mache ich auch Raid Shadow Legends.
Wobei ich da schon wirklich sehr viel Geld für haben möchte,
dass ich Raid Shadow Legends mache.
Auf den Scheiß habe ich nämlich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Auf der Arbeit lasse ich mich nicht bestechen.
Mietest einen 128 GB RAM-Riegel.
Ah, da wird es schon schwierig.
Den Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Z7 sehen?
Wie sicher die sichere Lösung ist?
Hä?
Das kann ich dir jetzt gerade nicht folgen.
Du meinst, ich soll eine KI drauf ansetzen und sagen,
Probier das zu umgehen, oder was?
Achso.
Achso, achso, achso, ja.
Das ist an sich auch keine schlechte Idee.
Wir sagen hier...
Cloud Code.
Ich geb dir Zugriff auf den Kubernetes-Cluster.
Du bist Admin.
Versuch mal, die Anwendung zu starten
mit diesem Flag auf Disabled.
Das wäre eigentlich mal witzig auszuprobieren.
Und versuche es so zu machen, dass es keiner merkt, dass du gerade was machst.
Quasi so verdeckt wie möglich.
Das müsste man echt mal ausprobieren, was Claude dann da versucht.
Oder versuchen würde.
Ey, iPad-Autokorrektur, ohne Scheiß, soll ich mal was sagen?
Also ich habe jetzt ja schon wirklich sehr lange iPhones, ja, seit, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahren oder so.
Und ich habe den Eindruck, die Autokorrektur beim Schreiben ist schlechter als vor 15 Jahren.
Ich meine, es gab damals auch schon bescheuerte Autokorrektur, ja.
Ich sag nur das hier, Juggernaut.
Falls das noch irgendjemand...
Moment.
Ah, man findet das Bild nicht.
Ja.
Also
Die Autokorrektur damals war jetzt auch nicht die geilste, ne?
Guck mal, ich wollte damals einen Tweet machen, damals als Twitter noch Plaumer
Wollte ich einen Tweet machen, habe Juggernaut geschrieben
Und guck mal die Autokorrektur dafür
Also die war damals auch nicht so die allerbeste, die Autokorrektur
Aber trotzdem, ich habe den Eindruck, die Autokonjunktur ist noch beschissener geworden.
Was, so diese Woche, es gibt neue Euros?
Wie, neue Münzen oder was?
Ach, Scheine, es gibt neue Euro-Scheine, aha.
ich habe so gut wie kein Bargeld mehr.
Ich bezahle nur noch alles mit
Karte, beziehungsweise mit
Kontaktlos, nicht mit Karte.
Kontaktlos mit
dem Smartphone.
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass
iPhone super unsicher sind. Ich weiß nicht, wie da
drauf kommt.
Das sind die neuen Euro-Scheine.
Die sehen ja
KI-generiert aus.
Sind das KI-generierte Euro-Scheine?
Nehmen Sie eine Unfrage teil.
Ja, ja, ich bin ein Mensch.
Sie können daran mitwirken.
Okay.
Vorschlag D.
Der geht eigentlich klar.
Naja, gut, der sieht kacke aus.
Aber da ist ganz...
Das ist ganz okay.
Next.
Okay, das sieht richtig kacke aus
Alter, das sieht mal richtig kacke aus
Ey, das hatten wir doch gerade schon, oder?
Hä?
Ah, das ist ganz okay
Ja
Das ist in Ordnung
Alter, was wollen die mit den scheiß Vögeln?
Geh mal weg
Das ist mit Fotos drauf
Ich finde Fotos
Passt da nicht wirklich
Oder so fotorealistisch
Kram.
Das gefällt mir nicht.
Alter.
Nervt nicht mit den Vögeln.
Gefällt mir auch nicht.
Noch mehr Vögel, Mann.
Das ist ja schlimm.
Das ist okay.
Weil ich das jetzt auch nicht so richtig geil finde.
Aber das geht noch irgendwie.
Wie alt sind Sie unter 18?
18 bis 24.
Ich bin 35 bis 44.
Ich bin divers.
In welchem Land leben Sie?
Slowenien.
Wie? Was ist Ihr höchster Bildungsabschluss?
Bin dumm.
Wo haben Sie, abgesehen von dieser Umfrage, schon gehört?
Auf Twitch.
Okay, top.
Haben wir unseren Dienst als Europäer getan.
Andorra, stimmt. Shit.
Ich wohne ja, habe ich ja ganz vergessen, ich wohne ja in Andorra.
Das habe ich mitbekommen, ja.
Das habe ich mitbekommen.
Du hast den besten Vorschlag einfach geskippt.
Wirklich.
Aber ich habe Vögel geskippt.
Ich hatte keinen Bock mehr auf noch mehr Vogelscheine.
So, gucken wir mal, was auf GitHub trennt.
trendet, nicht trennt, trendet.
Oh Leute, ich hab's noch ganz schön
in den Beinen. Ich musste
gestern
eine Stunde zwölf war's, glaube ich,
rennen.
Ja.
Eine Stunde zwölf, das merke ich echt
noch ziemlich in den Beinen.
Und heute muss ich wieder 46 Minuten ran.
Gestern
1 Stunde 12
144er Puls
11 knapp, bisschen über 11 Kilometer
Das heißt 630er Pace
Und angeblich habe ich 917 Kalorien verbraucht
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen viel
Aber heute muss ich nochmal 46 Minuten ran
Da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock
Okay, gucken wir mal
Was trennt er denn diese Woche?
AI
Wer hätte das nur?
wird. Da wären wir ja nicht AI.
Das hätten wir uns nicht denken können.
Hast du dir
den Trainingsplan selber erstellt? Nee.
Mit der Garmin-App.
Oder mit der Garmin-Uhr. Je nachdem, wie man es nimmt.
Das ist nämlich geil,
wenn man das mit der...
Das ist richtig gut, wenn man das mit
Garmin macht,
dann nimmt das quasi dein
aktuellen Trainings-Level
mit da rein.
Und wie ausgelastet du bist und sowas.
Also wenn du zum Beispiel, wenn du...
Also theoretisch kannst du damit ja auch deinen Schlaf tracken, ja.
Also wenn du schlecht geschlafen hast, kriegst du ein bisschen weniger Training.
Wenn du richtig gut performt hast, dann ist vielleicht dein Run ein bisschen schneller.
So nach dem Motto, okay, wir haben jetzt gesehen, du bist ein bisschen besser geworden.
Wir machen jetzt anstatt 6,30 6,25 und sowas.
Also das passt sich deinem aktuellen Trainingsstand an.
Diese Garmin-Workouts-Geschichte.
Das ist halt sehr nice.
Weil wenn du Trainingspläne hast, die sind halt statisch.
Okay, AI, AI, AI.
AI.
Äh, nicht AI, hatten wir aber schon.
Minecraft-Server.
In Rust, natürlich.
Selbstverständlich muss ein Minecraft-Server auch rewritten werden in Rust.
Wo kämen wir denn da hin, wenn das noch nicht in Rust rewritten werde?
Krock.
Das haben wir das letzte Mal schon gesehen.
Transfer, Secure.
Da habe ich den, ehrlich gesagt, den Sinn nicht so ganz verstanden.
Ich kann doch einfach SCP verwenden.
Oder nicht.
Also, ich verstehe es gerade noch nicht ganz, was der riesen Vorteil davon ist.
Ach so, jetzt habe ich es gecheckt.
Man kriegt da einen Code und den Code gibt man ein und dann wird es transferiert.
Achso, man braucht jetzt nicht wie bei SCP direkte Verbindung quasi, sondern kann sich das irgendwie auch tunneln und sowas.
Okay, das ist in der Tat sehr nice.
Das ist cool.
Es braucht aber halt Zugriff auf GetCrock wahrscheinlich.
Darüber werden die Files getunnelt, vermute ich mal.
Okay, aber jetzt, das ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
AI?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Sam Rush? Ah, Refs.
Weiß ich nicht, was das ist.
Wahrscheinlich AI.
Hyperland?
Trended.
Wie?
Haben die nicht mehr Hyper-Chan?
Wo ist Hyper-Chan hin?
Warum ist Hyper-Chan...
War Hyper-Chan nicht mehr seriös genug, oder was?
Hyper-Chan ist weg.
Was trendet denn in Blazingly Fast Written in Rust?
Du bist nicht der einzige, der von der Zeit hier am Start ist.
Wir hatten ganz viele COD-Kiddies hier am Start.
So, was?
AI.
Minecraft, das hatten wir schon.
Was?
Okay, keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das hatten wir schon mal.
Jellyum Desktop.
Jellyfin.
AI.
Omnigad.
Desktop.
Okay, Bücher-Download-Kram.
Natürlich nur für Linux-Distributionen, ist klar.
AI.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was es bedeuten soll.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall AI.
PNPM.
Okay.
Package Manager.
Der die Pakete nur noch verlinkt und nicht jedes Mal neu runterlädt.
AI.
Oder?
Ne, nicht mal zwangsläufig.
Das ist diese komische Schildkröte.
Genau.
Wo ich den Sinn noch nicht davon genau verstanden habe.
Aber okay.
Ihr wisst, ich bin immer sehr skeptisch,
sehr kritisch, was so CLI-Tools angeht.
Ob ich die in meinen Workflow einbinde oder nicht.
So, was das hier sein soll?
Kein Plastenschimmer.
Quasi Teams, oder?
Ah nee, AI.
Okay, ja, ja.
Was sonst?
Und Rustdesk trendet.
Ich hab gehört, die indischen Scammer
benutzen mittlerweile auch
oftmals Rustdesk
und nicht mehr Anydesk oder Teamviewer.
Hold on, man. Don't redeem.
Ich hab früher mal fast jeden Tag
Kit Boga geguckt.
Also der hat wirklich jeden Zuschauer verdient.
Der Kerl macht das so gut und was dem da spontan immer einfällt, richtig krass.
Aber so diese ganze Scambaiting-Geschichte, das nutzt sich halt auch hart ab, ne?
Das ist halt mehr oder weniger immer das Gleiche, weil halt auch die Scams immer das Gleiche sind.
Und ich gucke vielleicht jetzt ab und zu, ich gucke jetzt einmal im Monat vielleicht noch irgendwie so Scambaiting-Highlights oder so.
Ansonsten gucke ich mir das gar nicht mehr an.
Wann kommt eigentlich mal wieder ein YouTube-Video?
Ey, sogar, ich müsste jetzt eigentlich unbedingt ein YouTube-Video machen,
weil ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es euch aufgefallen ist,
aber der Frasier, übrigens das Video wollte ich ihm nicht zeigen, das Video nicht.
Der Frasier, das war der Frasier von 14 Jahren,
der Frasier hat tatsächlich, stellt euch das mal vor,
ein neues Video hochgeladen, in dem er Black Ops 7 spielt.
Sachen gibt's, oder?
youtube passwort gefunden
ok was in gold randes ganz schön viele tattoos ja mittlerweile kraft ist ja alles voll
soll das hat man gerade schon alibaba open code review
high performance self-hosted newsletter und mailing list manager ein plastenschimmer
wofür man das überhaupt braucht mailing listen das ist so was 1995 hat angerufen
es benutzt postgres postgres immer uns ja eigentlich postgres schon mal beste chat
jetzt weiß ich wieder was ich euch fragen wollte jetzt weiß ich wieder was ich euch fragen wollte
jetzt wo ich kein postgres gehabt also chat high iq es haben wir schon ein paar leute
subscribed hat iq geboostet jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt es auf den den chat iq an also wir
Wir haben eine Postgres-Datenbank.
Die Postgres-Datenbank wird regelmäßig gebackupt auf ein Bucket in der Google Cloud und verschlüsselt on-prem auf, keine Ahnung, Tape Library oder so.
So, jetzt ist es so, wir sind dazu gesetzlich verpflichtet, diese Postgres-Datenbank zu archivieren.
archivieren und zwar mit einem snapshot quasi wenn man so will also mit mit mit einem stand also mit einem stand
von einem tag so also mit daily snapshots sind wir gezwungen glaube ich zehn jahre
gesetzlich vorgeschrieben wie das zehn jahre oder 15 jahre ich weiß nicht lange zu archivieren
so dass beispielsweise jemand sagen könnte in acht jahren
Wie war denn
eurer datenbau oder was stand in eurer datenbank drin oder bestimmt die
interessieren ja auch nur bestimmte werte welche wissen wir nicht genau ja
also was waren die werte in der datenbank also in acht jahren schreibt
er das ja was waren denn die werte der datenbank am 26 juli 2026
jetzt das ding wie macht man das am besten
Ich glaube nicht, dass Event-Sourcing da drauf eine Antwort ist.
Zumal das eine Anwendung ist, die da reinschreibt, die wir selbst nicht programmieren.
Wie würdet ihr das machen?
Wie würdet ihr Daily Postgres Snapshots so speichern,
dass man möglichst einfach noch in 8 Jahren...
Ach, du meinst hier Wall-Geschichten bei Postgres oder was?
Nee.
Brauchst du für den Snapshot nicht auch eine Datenbank?
Ja gut, die Datenbank ist ja da.
Aber in der Datenbank
steht ja nicht unbedingt
alles drinne der letzten 10 Jahre.
Barman.
Wir brauchen die Datenbanken
wohlgemerkt nur read-only.
Nur read-only.
Leider habe ich noch kein Tool gefunden, was Postgres-Dumps direkt querien kann.
Man braucht immer eine laufende Postgres-Datenbank.
Was nicht so wild ist, im Zweifelsfall installiere ich mir auf irgendeiner x-beliebigen Linux-Kiste eine Postgres-Datenbank und spiele den Dump ein.
Was ja wohl auch geht...
Ja gut, aber dazu muss ich doch...
Aber warte mal, warte mal.
Dazu muss ich doch...
Das muss doch die Anwendung machen.
Die Anwendung programmieren wir ja nicht.
Was kann ich mit Barman machen?
Das Dump Query?
Ne, die Datenbank einspielen.
Was ich gelesen habe ist...
Genau, was ich gelesen habe ist, Postgres ist wohl der Meinung,
dass man alte Datenbank-Dumps auch immer in neue Postgres-Versionen einspielen kann.
Nur umgedreht nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob sie es garantieren oder ob sie einfach nur sagen, das sollte in der Regel klappen.
Also Postgres sagt, man kann ein PG-Dump, also ein Dump, das man gezogen hat,
mit einer alten Postgres-Version auch in eine neue Postgres-Version einspielen.
Ob das in acht Jahren auch immer noch der Fall ist, weiß ich nicht, aber Postgres sagt das zumindest.
Dann würde ich mich jetzt mal so weit drauf verlassen.
Wisst ihr, was ich für eine doofe Idee hatte, um möglichst unabhängig von Postgres und allem möglichen Kram zu sein?
Ihr könnt mir das jetzt ausreden, okay?
Ich hatte die Idee, ich mache einen CSV-Export von einer Datenbank einmal am Tag und komprimiere den dann.
Das ist eine schlechte Idee, oder? Ist das eine gute Idee?
Weil der Vorteil
der Vorteil von CSV ist,
das ist Plaintext.
Da kann ich in 8 Jahren immer noch reingucken.
Das wird halt relativ groß.
Aber wenn ich es komprimiere,
sollte das eigentlich handelbar sein.
Da haben wir dann pro Tag
dann haben wir dann halt pro Tag
irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 10 Gig oder so
nochmal einen Dump, aber wen juckt's?
Ich habe auch keine...
Also Datenbanken ist was, da kannst du mich nichts zu fragen.
Ja, sagen sie ja auch.
Ich bin mir halt nicht sicher, ob sie es wirklich garantieren,
dass sie sagen, ja, das wird auf jeden Fall so sein.
Oder ob sie nur sagen, ja, wir gehen davon aus, dass es so ist.
kannst du auch gleich nach SQLite
konvertieren und so abschalten. Das ist
eine mega geile
Idee. Wisst ihr, was ich gedacht
habe? Ich habe mir
das gedacht, ich exportiere
das nach
CSV
und query das CSV mit
DuckDB. DuckDB kann
nämlich CSV querien.
Aber das ist eine
richtig gute Idee.
das macht nichts wir haben ja ein snapshot von jedem tag
wie groß ist die db also in unserer test umgebung glaube ich 24 gigabyte in produktion weiß ich
nicht ich weiß nur dass das sich an der datenbank ungefähr drei stunden dauert
sichern ist aber auch lahm es wird gedankt in s3 bucket und danach wird es
noch mal verschoben auf und bremen wo es dann verschlüsselt wird verschoben wird
auf innen und bremen backup system nur einmal am tag einmal nachts wird
gebackupt, ja?
Es macht auch keinen Sinn,
anderweitig zu backuppen.
Das sind immer Full Backups.
Du könntest den CSV-Snapshot
mit krimineller Energie als bösartig
manipulieren. Das wäre nicht nachvollziehbar.
Das stimmt.
Das willst du echt nach CSV exportieren?
Ja, ob ich das will, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber das ist das Beste, was mir einfällt.
Was baut ihr?
Wir haben eine Plattform.
Wie sage ich das, ohne dass man danach googeln kann?
Eine Plattform zum Verwalten von Krypto-Dingern auf verschiedenen Blockchains.
Und ein Teil davon wird in der Postgres-Datenbank gespeichert.
Wie wäre es mit die Postgres-Version zu sich, zum Beispiel abzuspeichern?
zu speichern.
Gut, ich glaube,
das braucht man, also das ja, das wäre eine Idee,
aber ich glaube, das braucht man nicht. Also ich glaube,
Postgres-Images von vor 10 Jahren, kriegst
du in 10 Jahren auch noch.
Zumal Postgres ja sagt, man kann auch mit neuen Versionen
alte Dumps herstellen.
Aber
SQLite finde ich eigentlich gar keine
schlechte Idee.
Postgres-Dump
to SQLite, gibt es da irgendwas,
was das macht?
aber best was offizielles was nicht die politik ist
ausgestattet
okay vielleicht das nicht das geilste tool dazu verwenden
easy to use
solution to create a school i data base von postgres damp
ja war stellt er gut es wäre nicht schlimm
Mir geht es ja um einen Daily Read Only Snapshot.
Read Only Snapshot.
Also ich verwende in Produktion weiterhin Postgres.
Kann das?
Online. Ja klar, ich lade das online hoch und ganz bestimmt.
Es gibt kein offizielles Tool.
Also warum ich auf CSV gekommen bin, ne?
PGDAM bzw. Postgres
kann selbst
als CSV-Datei speichern. Das geht.
Also Postgres kannst du sagen
Format SQL und sowas.
also das problem ist ja nur postkosten bank so und das kann sein dass in acht jahren jemand
kommt und sagt was stand denn in eurer datenbank am 26 7 2026 drinnen wie mache ich das am besten
die dams liegen dann irgendwie verschlüsselt auf einem offline nass rum oder auf einem tape
oder was auch immer. Wie mache ich das
am besten?
Also Postgres selbst sagt, ja, man
kann in alten Dump in die neue Postgres-Version
einspielen. Das sollte kein Problem sein.
Geht ihr da im CSV nicht
eine Menge flöten? Mich interessiert nur der Inhalt.
Der Rest ist mir egal.
Ich will daraus weder was restauren,
also
ich will nichts restauren,
oder sonst was damit machen.
Ich brauche nur
irgendwas, was ich sicher in 8 Jahren
noch lesen kann und mit ein bisschen
tricks auch querien kann sei es nur mit krepp oder so sagte b kann übrigens csv
square
ja gut aber wie wie greife ich dann auf die backups zu wie greife ich auf die
backups zu ich muss das backup ja eine postgres zurückrestoren das heißt ich
muss mich darauf verlassen dass das funktioniert noch in zukunft dass ich
ein altes backup in der neue postkarte ich muss eine alte postkarte und ich
brauche eine laufende postgres dazu mir also was ich halt viel geiler finden
würde ohne irgendwas dass ich einfach das dampf direkt werden könnte
Und ich tendiere halt aktuell...
Aber ich tendiere halt aktuell einfach zu CSV.
Nee, ins Git kommt das nicht.
Das wird CSV gedumpt, dann wird es komprimiert und dann wird es on-prem auf irgendeine Archivlösung geschrieben,
die letztendlich wahrscheinlich auf irgendwelche tapes schreibt unten drunter also speicherplatz
ist nicht das problem speicher haben wir da mehr als genug ich mache einen täglichen täglichen
vollen csv export das einzige ding ist halt ich bin mir nicht sicher wie groß das wird in
produktion weil produktion braucht jetzt schon eine ganze weile zu back up und wenn ich dann
da am Tag irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
selbst komprimiert noch 350
Gigabyte oder so.
CSV, das dauert ja ewig.
Das kannst du ja nicht machen.
Also keine Ahnung,
das, ähm,
also mich
hat jetzt noch nichts
komplett überzeugt, weder das, was ich mir ausgedacht
habe, noch was der Chat geschrieben hat, also ich weiß nicht genau.
CSV, okay.
Ja, genau.
Ich fände es halt geil,
wenn es ohne geht.
Also,
DuckDB kann das angeblich ganz gut,
CSV-Query.
Habe ich aber auch
selbst noch nie ausprobiert. Das müssten wir mal
ausprobieren. Ich müsste mir mal
einen 350 GB CSV erstellen
und mit DuckDB querien.
Oh, das ist...
Leute, ich überlege mir, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Weil direkt vom Tape-Querying geht nicht.
Ich muss das erstmal irgendwo hinrestoren.
Das heißt, ich brauche erstmal ein 53-Gig-Laufwerk.
Am besten SSD-Storage.
Um da dann dran zu gehen.
Das wäre tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach.
Ja, schon.
Aber ich will ja darauf zugreifen können, auf die Daten in dem Dump.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man inkrementelle CSV-Backups machen kann.
Keine Ahnung.
Und wie query ich die dann vor allem?
Aber es besteht, Chat, Chat, es besteht noch Hoffnung, dass man das vielleicht gar nicht braucht, sondern es reicht, dass ich täglich irgendwie die 50 Werte, die die interessieren, im Plaintext irgendwo ins Backup reinschreibe.
Vielleicht geht das auch.
Vielleicht muss es gar nicht die komplette Datenbank sein,
sondern nur ein paar Sachen, die die interessieren.
Vielleicht geht der Kelch nochmal an uns vorüber,
zehn Jahre Postgres
restauren können zu müssen.
Also eine richtig geile Lösung ist da irgendwie
nicht dabei.
Ah ja.
Das habe ich auch gesehen.
Bei meinem letzten Arbeitgeber hatten wir ein Warenwirtschaftssystem.
Das war noch auf Red Hat 4, glaube ich.
Ne, das war auf Red Hat 5.
Ich glaube, das war in Red Hat 5.
Und in der ETC Red Hat Release stand drin, dass es in Red Hat 4 ist.
Und da stand ein Kommentar drauf auf dem System.
Red Hat 5 als Red Hat 4 getarnt.
Stand da wirklich als Comment auf dem System.
Wahrscheinlich Message of the Day oder in der Red Hat Release.
Stand drin, Red Hat 5 als Red Hat 4 getarnt.
Und das hat man damals gebraucht, weil da irgendeine uralte Oracle DB drauf lief.
Und die wurde nur hochgefahren, um in dem alten wahren Wirtschaftssystem was nachzugucken.
Ist das Oracle 8.5, kann das sein, oder bringe ich das durcheinander?
Oder 6.5?
Gibt's da so eine Version History?
Version History.
8.5. Gibt's gar nicht.
8 irgendwas. Juni 1997.
Nice.
Also irgendwas hiervon war das.
Von den Datenbanken her.
Krass, oder?
Red Hat 4.
Wann war das aktuell?
Lass mal gucken.
Okay.
Das gab es von 2005.
2005.
Das heißt im Endeffekt,
wir hatten in Red Hat 5 laufen,
was als Red Hat 4 getarnt war,
auf dem eine Datenbank von 1998 lief.
Okay, von 2000.
Eine Datenbank von 2000 lief.
Geil, oder?
So was willst du haben.
Excellent.
Und das wurde immer nur eingeschaltet,
wenn irgendwie einer aus dem alten wahren Wirtschaftssystem
was brauche.
Brauchte.
Chat, ich weiß,
ich habe euch jetzt viel schon gefragt,
aber ich muss euch noch was fragen.
Ich finde dafür immer
keine richtige Antwort
und ich bekomme da auch immer keine richtige Antwort.
von leuten die oracle fans sind was ist der große vorteil also warum sollte man oracle anstelle von
postgres benutzen das konnte mir noch kein oracle fan erklären da hörst du dann immer so dinge wie
wie, ja, professionelles System oder lang getestet und Erfahrung oder der SQL-Dialekt wäre so gut oder sowas.
Das hat mich alles nicht so überzeugt.
Wenn ich jetzt was aufbaue, was brauche ich für, also was müsste ich haben,
oder was für Anforderungen müsste ich haben, dass ich wirklich eine Oracle DB benutzen muss,
anstelle von einer Postgres?
Also, das konnte mir noch keiner
auch der ganzen Oracle-Fans erklären.
Performance bei großen DBs.
Ist das wirklich so?
Der Besitzer von Oracle
hat was mit der Tochter von Markus Söder.
Ist der Besitzer von Oracle nicht 70 oder so?
Na gut, das hält ihn ja nicht davon ab.
Das ist recht wahrscheinlich.
Ja, okay, das stimmt wohl.
Es gibt Oracle-proprietäre SQL-Commands.
Aber die muss ich ja nicht benutzen.
Gerade wenn ich eine neue Anwendung baue, wäre ich doch blöde.
Wäre ich doch richtig blöde, wenn ich SQL baue,
was nur in Oracle funktioniert.
Und wenn ich das mache,
dann müsste es ja so einen immensen Vorteil
haben, das darin zu machen,
dass das alle Vorteile von Postgres überwiegt.
Und das
konnte mir noch keiner erklären.
Okay, also ihr wisst das auch nicht.
Also falls jemand
von euch mal irgendeine glorreiche Idee hat,
sagt es mir, weil ich
Ich hab, ohne Scheiß, ich hab noch kein mich überzeugendes Gegenargument gehört, warum es denn unbedingt eine Oracle sein muss.
Okay, das lass ich, ja, wobei, mir geht's ja für neue Sachen, ja.
Wenn jetzt einer eine 20 Jahre alte Anwendung hat, die in super verschachteltem Oracle-eigenem SQL-Syntax geschrieben ist.
Okay, dass man es weiter auf Oracle lässt, das verstehe ich, ja, aber es geht mir ja um neue Sachen.
Ja, das höre ich auch öfters, aber jetzt
konnte mir noch keiner sinnvoll begründen, warum.
Deswegen, das würde mich
wirklich interessieren. Aber vielleicht gibt es ja
da wirklich was, wovon ich einfach als
Datenbank-Noob keine Ahnung habe.
audit funktionen
eigentlich ob man das mit postkursen ja auch alles machen kann hat postgres
mmc system ich habe nicht meine ahnung was mmc überhaupt ist
Multimastercluster.
Ich glaube, das hat Postgres nicht.
Glaube, glaube ich.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es das da nicht auch gibt mittlerweile.
Ich glaube, Postgres-Clustering läuft hauptsächlich so,
dass du ein Read, ein Write-Knoten hast
und sonst Read, Read, alles andere Read-Replikas sind.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es Multimastercluster,
Multi-Write-Cluster-Postgres gibt.
Okay, gehen wir mal davon aus,
das wäre der Fall und würde dann
bei richtig krassen, fetten, write-heavy
Anwendungen
Oracle besser machen.
Da musst du erstmal so eine
ultra-krass-technische write-heavy
Anwendung haben.
In dem Ausmaß, wo du das nicht mehr mit Postgres
abbilden kannst.
Was 99,9% der Anwendungen nicht sein werden.
Also weiß ich nicht.
Also ich bin da noch nicht überzeugt von.
Wir wollten übrigens gucken, was in Go trendet die Woche.
Grog to Arpy.
Ich weiß noch nicht, was Grog-Bild und Grog-Web und Grog-Konsole überhaupt sein sollen.
Das ist irgendwas...
Die KI von Elon, oder?
Okay, whatever.
Pocket Base. Pocket Base ist Proc.
Okay, dann wäre das tatsächlich ein Vorteil.
Aber wie gesagt, du brauchst erstmal eine Anwendung, wo das überhaupt zum Tragen kommt.
Was wahrscheinlich 99,9% der Anwendungen nicht sein werden.
Pocket Base, ja.
WX Channels Download, China-Chinesen-Kram.
Neko. Heißt Neko nicht Katze auf Japanisch?
Also quasi hier, Wupp, Wupp, Pet.
Self-Hosted Virtual Browser.
Noch mehr China-Chinesen-Kram, Netdata.
Du hast jetzt eine Katze.
13 Wochen.
Excellent.
Du hast die Heer aus dem Tierheim.
Ei, ei, ei, ei, ei.
Bauernhof.
Aha.
Max, warst du mal wieder im Tierheim?
Ja, aber es ist schon eine ganze Weile her.
Ich gehe da öfters mal zum Katzenstreicheln hin.
Und spende dann immer was, deswegen darf ich da auch immer hin.
Er-Klon ist Pock.
Oh, hier gibt es Bilder von der Cat.
und das muss man sich mal angucken
auch ja
niedliche katz so was ist was ist das hier okay pocket base pocket pocket base
kennen wir pocket base ist sehr nice auch wenn ich noch nie was mit pocket
base gemacht habe alles was ich darüber gesehen habe ist das gerade für front
endstelle leute
das ist es mit web sockets und alle möglichen gedöns du hast user management
und sowas es ist ein bisschen so was wie firebase nur als single go binary
eigentlich richtig cooles projekt für frontend leute die einfach im backend
was haben wollen gegen das sie api mäßig reden können und sich nicht ums
Backend kümmern wollen.
Das ist Pocket Base, richtig nice.
WX Channels Download.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Monkass.
Was?
Was bin ich sehend?
Okay.
Wir müssen mal kurz Chrome starten.
Und mal gucken, was ich hier sehe.
Überhaupt.
WX Downloads, translate to English.
WeChat Video Downloader.
Ist WeChat nicht quasi so dieses China WhatsApp oder China Telegram oder wie man das nennen mag?
Der China-Chinesen Messenger.
Online Sharing Link Parsing.
Ein WeChat Downloader.
Das ist der China Messenger, ja.
Okay.
Juckt mich nicht.
Er self-hostet Virtual Brother,
that runs in Docker and uses WebRTC.
Hä?
Das ist auch ein geiles Logo, Alter.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz schlüssig, wozu ich das brauche.
Aus Sandbox-Gründen, oder was?
Ah, Access Internet Security and Privacy from anywhere.
Okay, ja. Ja, ja, okay, verstehe, verstehe.
sub2 api ok eigens chat nur mal kurz zum drüber scrollen ich will jetzt gar nicht so sehr c++
flame weil es achtet immer aus okay hyperland moonshine trends terminal kein schimmer ein
game tensorflow free cad pro to barth media px folgs das ist hier linux gaming geschichte hex
editor ein ps4 ps5 emulator sunshine fork das ist dieses nvidia game streaming geschichte
fmt ja das ist auch der einzige weg wie du in c++ gescheit print line machen kannst mittlerweile
haben sie auch nach standard library okay was für eine sprache aber noch gucken wir haben
noch irgendwas spannendes ich will nicht immer jedes mal alles gucken weil es ist auch nicht
mal, da können sie auch fahren, das ist das gleiche. Kobol.
Okay, immer noch das gleiche.
Go hatten wir schon. Rust hatten wir auch schon.
Sick.
Ha! Ja, okay. Okay.
Just for fun.
Financial
Transaction Database.
Nullclaw.
Rock.
Codex.
Ghost. Ghost, die ist in Sick.
Aha.
Browser.
Das ist ein guter Name, einfach Browser.
Kelly.
Pac-Man Alternative for Arch Linux.
Designed with you in mind.
Aha.
Zig selbst.
AI.
Wayland-Stells.
Language Server
Any model any hardware das klingt nach AI
Native
Okay, was meint ihr brain fuck
Da trennt tatsächlich was.
Demisto, das kenne ich irgendwie.
Aber der Typ heißt so, oder?
Ja, da kenne ich das.
Genau.
Ixor.
Demisto.
Das muss ich beim alten Arbeitgeber mal installieren.
Da habe ich mit einem Typ von der Telekom
zwei Stunden oder so
Videokonferenz, also
Desktop-Sharing-Konferenz gemacht,
um den Krempel zu installieren.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel dran.
Genau dieses Ding.
Okay, das ist ein Hex-Editor
in C++.
Ist auch witzig, ne?
Screenshots vom Hex-Editor
zeigt alles nur nicht Hex-Editor.
ja doch hier hier was haben wir denn hier schönes kai tai ps4 ps5 emulator
der vier jahre alt ist ich sage einfach mal der hat nie richtig funktioniert
Und wird anscheinend auch nicht weiterentwickelt.
Warum trennt er denn überhaupt gerade?
Weiß man nicht.
Shelly ALPM.
Modern Arch Package Manager.
Okay.
Und warum ist der so geil?
Gibt es da ein paar Screenshots oder so?
Warum ist der besser als Pac-Man
oder Yay oder sonst was?
Weil ganz ehrlich,
ich hatte jetzt da wenig
Usability-Probleme bisher mit dem Arch-User-Package-Manager.
Mit dem Arch-Package-Manager.
Der kommt mittlerweile
default in Cache.js, okay.
Also ALPM
muss ich habe das noch nicht ich habe nur packen es wäre ja mal sinnvoll
irgendein beispiel zu bringen oder auch die features modernes juli native arch
integration und end ach das ist das ist eine gui oder was ja dann hätten wir
mal ein paar Screenshots machen können.
Ne, es ist ein... Hä?
Es ist ein CLI
und ein GUI. Ach, Sumo.
Okay,
das ist in der Tat ziemlich cool.
Arch User Repo Support,
Flatpak Support
und die Standard. Das ist ja nice.
Das finde ich cool.
Das gefällt mir.
Okay, das ist eine .NET Anwendung. Endlich mal einer, der in einer gescheiten Sprache was programmiert.
Da interessiert mich aber mal wieder die C-Sharp-GTK-Bild... Moment, das ist ein SIG.
What? Moment, ich bin verwirrt.
.NET Test? Aber ich denke, es ist ein...
Ich denke, es ist ein SIG.
hä die gui aber die aber die grüße auch in sich zum teufel hat das mit dort zu
tun
jetzt setzt play jetzt bin ich jetzt wirklich nicht mehr durch sie als ich
jetzt ja angeblich auch nicht die scharpe
Oh, Alter GitHub, fuck mich nicht ab.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Yay, Shelly.
Binster, nimm das jetzt einfach mal.
Moment, warum ist die CLI Beta?
Achso, das ist die Beta, das ist die Nicht-Beta.
Shelly.
gute idee gibt es nicht dass solution dateien
die githubsuche
also echt kein plan aber wir installieren das jetzt einfach mal
jetzt haben wir hier für versions 2414 okay shelly wie geht das jetzt
Ach, der würde auch Flatpak updaten.
Äh, no.
Ähm, Flatpak?
Den ganzen Flatpak-Shit kann ich mal wieder aninstallen, das war hier nur zum was ausprobieren.
auf die freshen hier weg damit
jetzt noch mal
habe ich so viel flatback schiss installiert
Na gut, wen juckt's?
Aber das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Ja, vielleicht, vielleicht verwende ich...
So, wie startet man jetzt das?
Also, dass man schon mal...
Mich nervt schon mal, dass man nicht Ctrl-C drücken kann.
Ja, also das finde ich schon mal doof.
Oder dass es ein bisschen laggy ist mit Ctrl-C.
Guck, ich drücke jetzt Ctrl-C und das brauche ich immer.
Ah, vielleicht muss ich mehrfach Ctrl-C drücken.
Ne.
Guck, das laggt immer richtig.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube...
Ist ja Gewohnheitstier, ne?
Aber warum .NET?
Da muss ich jetzt echt mal...
echt mal danach suchen.
Warum .NET?
.NET?
Mutex in UI.
Warum anhält er diese Würfe?
War das vielleicht mal in .NET und er hat es in SIG rewritet?
Oder wie?
Oder was?
Ich will mal gucken, was da was davon.
Okay, Recommended CS.
So, da können wir jetzt gucken.
Files changed.
Shelly GTK.
Ach, Windows.
Achso
Shelly GTK Windows
Das ist
Alter, der will es aber wissen
GTK
Unter Windows
Mit diesen ekligen GTK C-Sharp Bindings
MonkaW
Das ist ja krasser Shit
Der wird bestimmt noch richtig kotzen müssen
Letztendlich ist es aber eh nur ein Webview oder was
Ah, gut.
Na gut.
Jetzt weiß ich aber auch, wo da die
Internet-Geschichten herkommen.
Was ist das?
Lipfaxes.
A modern TUI library written in SIG.
Wie wärs mit A?
Okay.
Äh.
Ist da vielleicht ein paar Features zu sehen?
Ne.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal, wie sieht die Progression...
Progress aus.
Also ohne Screenshots ist es ja schon ziemlich suck.
oder
ja
Examples
ich finde so Terminal Libraries
immer ganz spannend
aber das Ding ist halt
es gibt wenig Sprachen
meiner Meinung nach
wo es gescheite Terminal Libraries gibt
Table
Also ganz ehrlich, Rust hat nichts gescheites, Go hat nichts gescheites, Python hat was ziemlich
Gutes mit Ridge, C-Sharp hat was ziemlich Gutes mit Spectre Console. Ruby wüsste ich jetzt nicht,
C++, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich muss sagen,
Ridge und Spectre Console ist halt einfach
beste.
Keine Ahnung, warum es in anderen Sprachen
nur so schlechte
Terminal Libraries gibt.
Ach, ich war bei Shelly
im Development Branch.
War ich das?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Ja, das sieht deutlich mehr nach .NET aus.
Shelly CLI.
Moment, sehe ich das richtig?
Die rewriten Shelly gerade von .NET in SIG.
Benutzen System Command Line, oder?
Ist das System Command Line?
Warum wechselt man von einer schönen Sprache wie C Sharp zu einer zweckmäßigen Sprache wie SIG?
Ja gut, für Native Binaries lasse ich mir das schon gefallen. Da ist es mit SIG wahrscheinlich besser. Gerade unter Linux.
Wobei .NET IoT auch große Fortschritte gemacht hat.
Okay, aber das sieht tatsächlich schon deutlich mehr nach .net jetzt aus.
Aber viele Sachen sind ja jetzt schon in SIG gewesen, ne?
Viele Sachen waren ja damals auch schon in SIG.
Also der hat SIG und C-Sharp interop gemacht quasi dann.
Ich meine, SIG kannst du wahrscheinlich ohne Probleme als PC-Interface callen.
Also das müsste schon funktionieren.
Okay, was ist ZR-Mix?
Session attached, detached for
Terminal.
Das ist sowas wie
T-Mux. Nur
mit SIG.
But why?
You might not need T-Mux.
Ja, okay, mag sein.
Ich need auch kein T-Mux,
außer auf dem Server.
Aber bevor ich irgendeine
T-Mux-Alternative verwende, kann ich einfach
T-Mux verwenden, weil T-Mux ist
Tested, Feature-Rich
und ich bin dran gewöhnt.
Also, auf jedem Server
ist ein Temux am Start,
ein ZMX eher nicht.
Toolkit for building native desktop applications.
In welcher Sprache?
SICK.
Okay, kein...
Zack, machen wir mal hier zu.
Gut.
So, GitHub Trends, fertig.
Habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Nee.
Ach, Sigg ist jetzt gar nicht mehr auf GitHub.
Aber ihre meisten User haben sie wahrscheinlich trotzdem noch durch GitHub.
Also die entwickeln jetzt auf Codeberg, aber synken bestimmt nach GitHub.
Weil wer nicht auf GitHub gefunden wird, existiert halt nicht.
Standardformat ist by the way FMT-Lib.
Das ist FMT-Lib in Standard gegossen worden vor ein paar Jahren.
Aber FMT-Lib kann natürlich mittlerweile mehr.
Und konnte damals auch.
auch schon mehr. Das haben die nicht alles
in Standard gepackt.
Schon das neue
TypeScript 7 Video gesehen. Ach!
Ist das jetzt raus?
TypeScript 7 mit
TypeScript in Go?
Ist das jetzt am Start?
Das habe ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Also ich habe mitbekommen, dass sie die ganze
Zeit ja an dem
TypeScript Compiler in Go
programmieren.
Aber ich wusste gar nicht, dass das schon raus ist.
Moment, das muss ich mal gucken.
Gibt es da ein gescheites Video zu?
TypeScript 7.
Da ist er.
Der Anders ist am Start.
Ich kann mir...
Das Blöde ist, ich kann mir Talks vom Anders nicht angucken.
Der sagt immer, ähm, ähm, ähm.
Gibt es da vielleicht ein besseres Video?
TypeScript 7 ist hier.
Vor einem Tag.
Der Chat sagt, seit Anfang Juli oder so.
Es ist seit einem Tag raus, Chat.
Anscheinend gibt es da...
Warte mal, lass mal gucken hier. Filter.
Die letzte Woche, okay.
Oder einfach...
Okay, wir skippen mal kurz.
Aber ich finde, Anders ist super schwer zuzuhören.
Er sagt immer ähm, ähm die ganze Zeit.
Darf ich den Link schicken? Klar.
Ähm, da geht's schon los.
Da geht's schon los.
Die halben Videos von dem bestehen immer aus ähm.
Ich scroll mal ein bisschen vor.
Wobei, das Anfangen hören wir uns noch an.
Aktuell ist er noch ganz gut drauf.
Er ernt noch nicht so viel.
jetzt auf NPM, monatlich. Und weniger als ein Jahr her wurde TypeScript das Nummer eins
Programm-Wert, was auf GitHub steht. Wenn Sie mich zehn Jahre her gefragt hätten, ob ich
das jemals möglich machen würde, hätte ich Ihnen gesagt, dass ich es nicht machen würde.
Aber es ist offensichtlich sehr schmutzig und sehr motivierend für unser Team.
Okay, komm mal noch zurück. Heute kann man ihm echt ganz gut zuhören.
Mit einer Community so groß, schreiben viele Projekte. Und einige dieser Projekte sind
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
Oh, Moment, Moment.
1,3 Billionen, das heißt 1,3 Milliarden.
Die Amis rechnen ja so komisch.
Okay, jetzt geht's los.
Und auf dieser Maschine habe ich beide TypeScript 6 und TypeScript 7 Seite für Seite installiert.
Und ich werde den alten Compiler TypeScript 6 benutzen, um das ganze Visual Studio Code Projekt zu kompilen.
Und dann können wir reden, während das passiert.
war auch am Start. Also der ist massive big brain der Typ. Aber ich kann mir die Vorträge nicht anhören.
Ich bin froh, dass ich TypeScript noch nicht an meinem Body fühle.
Fühlt ihr TypeScript auch an eurem Body?
Wenn es nicht eine Leistung ist, ist es aus der Erinnerung.
Also, vor etwa zwei Jahren haben wir zuerst ein Experiment gestartet und dann ein Projekt getroffen,
um das gesamte Toolset zu bewegen.
Und by the way, ich habe schon ein paar Mal gesagt, der Grund, warum es Go geworden ist,
hat ja ein paar Rust-Fans getriggert.
Die haben gesagt, warum rewrite ihr das in Go und warum rewrite ihr das nicht in Rust?
und Rust ist doch die beste Sprache.
Wie kann das sein, dass das nicht rewritet wird in Rust?
Ich habe das damals gesagt,
noch bevor
wir das Video zu der Ankündigung
geguckt haben. Und eines
meiner Punkte war, dass
Compiler gerne mal so selbstreferenzierte
Strukturen haben.
Also Sachen, die auf sich selbst
verweisen.
Also sowas wie eine Linked List oder sowas.
Und das ist
in Rust echt eklig.
Und das haben die dann ja auch
bestätigt, als wir das Video damals geguckt haben.
Also das ist tatsächlich ein Punkt.
Und sie sagen,
TypeScript und Go
sind sich ähnlich genug,
dass man den Code relativ
easy von TypeScript
zu Go portieren kann,
sodass man quasi das gleiche Verhalten
in Go hat
und es nebeneinander lesen kann
zu TypeScript. Rust sieht komplett
anders aus und ist auch in der Handhabung komplett
anders. Wenn du nicht alles voller Unsave
packen willst. Ja, du kannst es natürlich so machen wie
Bann, die
portiert haben von SIG zu
Rust, allerdings dann alles
unsafe.
Twitch braucht vier Minuten, um einen Livestream zu laden.
Krass.
Bist du da? Bist du gerade über Satellit?
Bist du im Erdorbit irgendwo?
Achso, ja gut, du hörst das jetzt ja gar nicht, was ich sage.
Okay, gucken wir mal weiter.
Also Leute, wisst ihr jetzt, was ich meine?
Nur mal, dass ich es jetzt checke.
Compile Times, also zwischen TypeScript 6, was noch selbst in TypeScript geritten war,
versus TypeScript 7, das jetzt in Go written ist.
Das heißt, Visual Studio Code 2,8 Milliarden?
Fragezeichen...
Das wäre ganz schön viel, oder?
Er hat vorher Billion gesagt.
Billion sind Milliarden.
Hat er nicht?
Hat er nicht vorhin Billion gesagt?
Weil das wäre ganz schön viel.
Okay.
2,3 Millionen.
Okay, da habe ich mich verhört. 1,9 Millionen. Das heißt, das Ding ist saumäßig viel schneller. Ja gut, das ist schon ein Unterschied, ob du Visual Studio Code in quasi zwei Minuten kompilierst oder in zehn Sekunden. Also das ist schon mal ein heftiger Unterschied.
Das ist schon ordentlich.
nicht zu dem reichenden Code.
Oh, 6-7!
Hört mir bloß auf, das ist übrigens schon wieder total out.
Die ganze Gen-Z sagt das gerne,
Gen-Z hat das ja noch nie gesagt,
Gen-Alpha und Beta und Cäsar und was auch immer dann da ist,
die haben das gesagt.
Und die sagen das nicht mehr,
weil da rennt es halt einfach nur noch eine Woche
und dann ist es vorbei.
Das ist sau schnell.
Ja.
Cringe sagt man, sagt man, also cringe kann man sagen, aber ich glaube, das ist jetzt kein typischer Gen-Alpha-Slang.
also wenn in meiner package chasing jetzt halb script größer gleich
sieben stadt wenn ich automatisch hätte ich jetzt gedacht ehrlich gesagt
hätte ich gedacht
ob das wirklich so ist
aber ich würde mal sagen ja
Richtig, richtig, natürlich.
Ja, du verwendest nicht Go für deine Anwendung, du verwendest den Compiler in Go, um aus TypeScript Java Code zu machen.
Ja, ja, das ist klar. Am Ende ist es immer noch JavaScript. Also für Runtime, Performance oder irgendwas hat es überhaupt keinen Unterschied. Es geht Compile Time und Tooling und sowas schneller ist.
Also JavaScript ist es am Ende immer noch und läuft dann im Browser auch oder mit Node auch mit JavaScript.
Genau, Pipelines sind schneller und sowas.
Das verstehe ich und Multithreading ist ja bekannt dafür, oder sagen wir mal umgedreht,
JavaScript ist ja bekannt dafür, dass Multithreading ein bisschen eklig ist.
Und Multithreading in Go ist halt richtig nice.
Das ist übrigens auch wichtig.
Das ist wichtig.
Es gibt auf der, also für jeden Bug in so einem größeren Projekt, gibt es mindestens einen auf der Welt, der darauf angewiesen ist, dass dieser Bug so buggt, wie er buggt.
Deswegen ist auch wichtig, dass auch Bugs portiert werden.
Du solltest erwarten, dass du dieses Werk genau so sehen kannst, wie TypeScript 6 es gemacht hat.
Minus ein paar...
JavaScript kann ich wirklich nicht wirklich multispeichern, das stimmt.
Du hast diese Geschichte, wie heißt das, diese Webworker-Geschichte.
Ja, also du kannst schon in Node.js mit ein bisschen Tricksen, kannst du Multithreading machen.
Aber es ist halt nicht zu vergleichen mit einer ordentlichen Sprache, wo Multithreading eingebaut ist.
Ich habe auch TypeScript 7 auf dieser Box installiert.
Und wir versuchen jetzt, mit, ähm, ups, nein,
ich sage einfach, TSC-NoEmit,
slash Diagnostics,
und wir kompilen mit dem Native Code Compiler.
Und wir sollten sehen, dass das viel schneller geht.
In Wahrheit, es schafft in etwa sechs, sechs und ein halb Sekunden hier.
Also prinzipiell geht das mit Webworkern, in Node geht Multithreading auch und wir haben mal im Stream einen Videoplayer programmiert in C++, den wir zu WebAssembly transpiled haben und der hat auch teilweise multithreaded und ich vermute, dass es unter der Haube halt auch Webworker verwendet hat.
... bis zu 7,5x.
Das ist wirklich schnell.
Wolltest du nicht mal 10x sagen?
Ich habe es schon gesagt.
Ich zeige dir die Unterschiede.
Das ist wirklich sehr zackig.
Von 47 Sekunden auf 6,5 Sekunden.
Von 47 auf 6.
Da kannst du dich beim besten Willen.
Das ist wirklich mega pock.
Es fühlt sich da noch alles viel snappier an.
Zunächst möchte ich hier nur sagen,
dass in dieser Kompilierung
jede Phase der Kompilierung
Emitterung ist langsamer. Hier oben ist sie wahrscheinlich hardcoded auf null.
Aber diese Maschine hier hat 16 Koren.
Wir können also noch besser arbeiten.
Ich werde es versuchen, es zu kompilen.
Aber dieses Mal werden 12 Type Checker gebildet.
Also verwenden wir etwa 3 Viertel meiner Koren für Type Checking.
Das wird natürlich Perf von anderen Jobs auslösen.
Aber wenn es keine anderen Jobs gibt, können Sie sie alle auslösen.
Nicht schlecht.
Jetzt sind wir schon bei 4,5 Sekunden.
Hier seht ihr, dass wir jetzt 4,5 Sekunden lang sind.
Jetzt sprechen wir also über 12x.
Und tatsächlich benutzt man die gleiche Erinnerung wie der alte Compiler,
aber es dauerte zehnmal länger.
Einer meiner Lieblings-Screengrabs ist dieser hier,
Das ist ein 32-Core, 128-Gig-Bildmaschine, die eine 15-Millionen-Linie-Codebase in TypeScript kompiliert.
Und Sie können hier für den Screengrab sehen, dass es jeden Core beschäftigt.
Nun, mit dem alten Kompiler würde man hier eine grüne Bar sehen und alle anderen CPUs würden warten.
Das ist das, was ich meine, wenn man die Gewinnung von Konkurrenz bekommt.
Es ist toll, dass man schnellere Kommandos baut, aber natürlich ist
die Sprache-Service das Wichtigste.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, weil das macht dann nicht nur das Compilen schneller,
sondern auch alles andere, alles was der Language Server bereitstellt.
Also Autocomplete und so Geschichten.
Und lass mich hier Visual Studio anfangen.
Chat sagt immer noch crazy, dass ein Microsoft-Angestellter ein Linux-Screenshot zeigt.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube mittlerweile ist es so, dass Microsoft intern viel mehr Linux-Fans hat als Windows.
Ich meine, Windows wird ja auch immer beschissener.
Microsoft gibt sich ja auch jegliche Mühe, dass die Leute gern Bock mehr auf Windows haben.
Language Server Protocol.
This doesn't really show up in data they use by you.
However, it means that it's a lot easier
to integrate this language service with other editors
and increasingly AI uses LSP also.
Es muss in jedem Microsoft Video mindestens, mindestens einmal AI
oder agentic oder irgendwie sowas kommen.
To do semantic validation of the code that it generates.
Auf dieser Maschine seht ihr, dass ich TypeScript 7 als Ausstattung installiert habe.
Eventuell wird TypeScript 7 die Default sein, aber wenn ihr Visual Studio installiert,
bekommt ihr immer noch TypeScript 6 und dann könnt ihr die Ausstattung installieren und die beiden werden zusammen existieren.
Nun, ihr seht hier unten in der Gutter, dass wir den nativen Sprachserver nutzen.
Also für mich ist wichtig, dass Autocomplete und sowas ordentlich funktioniert und nicht
leckt.
Das ist wirklich schnell, das ist wirklich schnell.
Ich habe jetzt wenig Vergleich dazu, ehrlich gesagt, wie das bei dem alten TypeScript Language Server war.
Weil die meisten Projekte dürften jetzt ja nicht in Größenordnung von Visual Studio Code sein.
Aber trotzdem, Performance ist nie verkehrt.
bringt es zurück, parsiert 8000 File und zeigt die roten Spiegelchen.
Und du hast gesehen, dass das weniger als zwei Sekunden dauerte.
Und um dir die Unterschiede zu zeigen,
versuchen wir, TypeScript 7 zu verlinken und zurück zu TypeScript 6 zu gehen.
Und hier wirst du sehen,
dass wir jetzt weggrinden.
Das dauert etwa 10 bis 12 Sekunden, um der alten Sprachnachricht
zu werden.
Das ist die Unterschiede zwischen den beiden.
Das bedeutet, dass es, wenn man auf großen Projekten arbeitet,
schon ein Unterschied ist. Es ruckelt und leckt dann einfach nicht so rum.
Es ist ziemlich gleich da.
TypeScript 7 ist stark battle-getestet.
Im letzten Jahr haben wir native Previews publiziert.
Wir hatten viele Industriepartner, die TypeScript 7 in dieser Previewphase verwendet haben,
uns Feedback gegeben und uns zurückgeleitet, was die Probleme waren.
Wir sprechen hier über ein Stück Code, das sehr stabil ist.
Und Sie sollten sich auf dramatische Performance-Bedrohungen erhoffen.
Ich würde definitiv empfehlen, dass Sie TypeScript 7 benutzen.
Sollte ich mal jemals was mit TypeScript machen in nächster Zeit, dann benutze ich auf jeden Fall.
Ich benutze dann immer die neuesten Versionen.
Wenn man eine Codebase hat, die auf den Compiler-APIs basiert.
Das würde z.B. bedeuten, wenn man Vue, Astro, Svelte oder Bolar benutzt,
muss man immer noch TypeScript 6 benutzen.
Deshalb können sie hier zusammenwachsen.
Wir arbeiten mit der Industrie und unseren Partnern daran,
... to build a new native code API and an API that you can call a cross process for the new compiler.
And that will...
Ja, anscheinend, anscheinend...
... ship in 7.1.
But if you don't need the API, absolutely, I think you should switch to TypeScript.
Ich muss sagen, ich mache zwar relativ gerne was ins Welt, aber eigentlich immer ohne TypeScript.
Das heißt, mir ist es für mich egal.
... 7.1 and enjoy all the free time you're going to get from this improved performance.
Thanks.
Excellent. Ja, aber er konnte ihm heute tatsächlich zuhören.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Das ist tatsächlich mal einer der wenigen erfolgreichen Rewrites, wo man sagen würde, ey, das hat richtig was gebracht.
Weil viele Rewrites sterben ja quasi auf dem Weg so.
Was ist das denn?
Cyberkriminella löscht die gesamte Grundbuchdatenbank eines Landes.
Aber habt ihr das mitgekriegt? Ich nicht.
Rumänien.
Doch, das habe ich gelesen.
Doch, doch, ich glaube, das habe ich gelesen.
Komplette Grundbuchdatenbank Rumäniens gelöscht.
Mit allen Backups.
Alles, was er dafür brauchte, waren gültige Zugangsdaten zur Behörde.
Seitdem steht der Immobilienmarkt des Landes still.
Der Fall wirft eine unbequeme Frage auf.
Sind die Sicherheitskonzepte von Behörden wirklich sicher?
Nö, das hätte ich aber auch vorher sagen können.
Ich meine, ihr passiert doch auch laufend irgendwas.
In Berlin konnten doch letztens Gerichte nicht mehr arbeiten, weil irgendwelche Probleme waren.
Dieser Frage gehen wir heute nach.
Ihr erfahrt in diesem Video, wie der Angriff ablief, welche Folgen das Land jetzt trägt
und warum dieser Fall eine kaputte Backup-Strategie infrage stellt.
Auch vielleicht eure?
Mal ehrlich, wie viel von eurem digitalen Leben liegt gerade auf amerikanischen...
Beginnen wir mit dem Ablauf.
Das Ziel des Angriffs war die ANCPI, die Nationale Katasterbehörde von Rumänien.
So eine Behörde kennt ihr vielleicht auch als Vermessungsamt.
Sie führt das Grundbuch des Landes, also das amtliche Register, das festhält, wem welches Grundstück gehört.
Der Angreifer lockt sich mit gültigen Zugangsdaten in die Systeme ein.
Einmal drin erkundete er in aller Ruhe das interne Netz und versuchte anschließend die Behörde zu erpressen.
Die Erpressung scheiterte allerdings.
Parallel dazu hatte er die erbeuteten Daten in speziellen Foren zum Verkauf angeboten.
Und dann macht er ernst.
Nach eigenen Angaben löschte er alle Systeme und die Backups gleich mit.
Im Darknet gab er außerdem damit an, die Sicherungskopien manipuliert zu haben.
Sein Ziel war klar. Er wollte jede Wiederherstellung der Daten verhindern.
Die Behörde sprach zuerst von technischen Problemen und räumte erst später ein, dass es sich um einen Cyberangriff handelte.
Öffentlich bekannt ist der Vorfall seit dem 14. Juli.
Schon einen Tag später tauchten erste Daten in einem Untergrundforum auf.
Darunter Zugangsdaten von Mitarbeitern, interne Dokumente und Details zum Netzwerk der Behörde.
Diese Löschung trifft aber nicht nur eine Behörde, sondern ein ganzes Land.
Der rumänische Immobilienmarkt steht seit dem Angriff still.
Die offiziellen Apps und Webseiten der Behörde sind nicht erreichbar.
Notare führen keine Transaktionen mehr durch und Bürger kommen weder an Eigentumsnachweise noch an detaillierte Grundbuchauszüge.
Wer also gerade ein Haus kauft oder verkauft, hängt in der Luft.
Überlegt mal, wie das in eurem Land so wäre. So ganz ohne Grundbuch.
Wir würden Faxe schicken.
Läuft dann nicht mehr viel.
Die Behörde spricht inzwischen von einer umfassenden Neuinstallation ihrer gesamten IT-Infrastruktur.
ihre techniker arbeiten dafür mit spezialisten für cyber sicherheit zusammen stellen daten
wieder her und verstärken die schutzmaßnahmen an die dienste laufen sagt die behörde allerdings
nicht damit kommen wir zum das ist aber auch wieder so ein ding wahrscheinlich hat die behörde
ein admin der sich um alles kümmern muss und dem werfen sie noch steckt und sie wollen wahrscheinlich
von security maßnahmen nichts hören kern des falls den backups denn hier widersprechen sich
die Beteiligten direkt. Der Angreifer behauptet, er habe alle Systeme und alle Backups gelöscht
und zusätzliche Sicherheitskopien manipuliert. Die Behörde stellt das ganz anders dar. In einer
Pressemitteilung erklärt sie, dass sie über mehrere Sicherheitskopien ihrer Systeme verfügt.
Diese Kopien sorgen laut Behörde für Redundanz. Sprich, die Daten existieren mehrfach an getrennten
Stellen und lassen sich im Ernstfall wiederherstellen. Normalerweise halten sich Behörden
an die Vorschriften der IT-Sicherheitsbehörden und diese ändern so komplexe Backup-Schemata
wie Rotation, Offline-Kopien und so weiter vor.
Ein krimineller Erpresser ist da nicht die beste Wahl, weil er die Behördenstrukturen eben nicht kennt.
Die Darstellung der Behörde ist vermutlich korrekt, aber die Wiederherstellung zieht sich hin.
Der Backup-Datenbestand hat wahrscheinlich einen gewissen Verzug.
Notare und so müssen ihre Änderungen wahrscheinlich noch nachtragen, und zwar für einige Tage, was auch nochmal Zeit in Anspruch nimmt.
Jetzt bleibt aber die Frage, wer hinter diesem Angriff steckt.
Die gestohlenen Daten veröffentlichte ein Account namens Byte2Breach.
to Breach. Die Sicherheitsfirma Kela geht davon aus, dass sich dahinter Zakira Matjub aus dem
algerischen Uran verbirgt. Derselbe Account drang Anfang des Jahres mutmaßlich in das schwedische
E-Government-Portal ein, griff möglicherweise auch staatliche Register in der Slowakei, der Ukraine,
Polen und Litauen an. Haltet euch das mal vor Augen, es handelt sich hier um keinen staatlichen
Geheimdienst mit großem Budget, sondern ein einziger Krimineller und der legt die Eigentumsdaten
eines ganzen EU-Landes lahm.
Dieser Fall zeigt aus unserer Sicht,
was dank einer guten Sicherheitsarchitektur
niemals passieren darf.
Ein Angreifer mit gültigen Zugangsdaten
durfte offenbar alles.
Ja, ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen,
dass dort die Leute auch schon gesagt haben,
ey, das ist unsicher.
Und dann haben die Leute, die das entscheiden müssen,
keinen Bock gehabt, was zu entscheiden.
Und dann blieb das halt so.
Daten lesen, Systeme löschen
und sogar Backups anfassen.
Genau das soll eine gute Architektur verhindern.
Stichwort für Interessierte ist hier Zero Trust.
Außerdem gehören Backups getrennt von Produktivsystemen auf Verwahrt.
Mit eigenen Zugängen und eigener Absicherung.
Am besten liegen sie offline auf einem Speicher,
der nachträglich niemand verändern kann.
Sonst löscht ein Angreifer die Kopien einfach mit.
Genau wie es hier passiert ist.
Und die Kommunikation der Behörde kritisieren wir.
Erst sprach sie von technischen Problemen,
dann räumte sie einen Angriff ein.
Und ihre Aussage zu den intakten Backups
widerspricht dem sichtbaren Stillstand.
So ein Verhalten kostet Vertrauen. Behörden verwalten
Daten. Ja, das wird in der Marsch vorbeigehen.
Bei uns juckt sich doch auch keiner mehr.
Ich meine, wir werden ja auch mittlerweile
regelmäßig angelogen.
Also ganz offensichtlich, so eine
Woche sagt man das, nächste Woche das. Ja, juckt
ja keinen. Es juckt
von politischer Seite mittlerweile keine
Sau mehr, ob er Mist erzählt.
... die es nur einmal gibt. Und genau deshalb schulden
sie den Bürgern belastbare Vorsorge und
ehrliche Kommunikation. Was nehmt ihr aus
dieser Geschichte mit. Sicherheit steht und fällt mit Backups, die einen Angriff überleben. Rumänien
zeigt gerade sehr deutlich, was sonst passiert, denn das Land hat den Zugriff auf seine Eigentumsdaten
verloren. Prüft deshalb eure eigene Strategie. Trennt eure Backups vom restlichen Netz und am
besten sogar räumlich. Nutzt Kopien, die sich nachträglich nicht verändern lassen und testet
die Wiederherstellung regelmäßig. Ein Backup, das ihr nie zurückgespielt habt, ist am Ende nur eine
Hoffnung und das gilt für Behörden genauso wie für Unternehmen und vielleicht auch euren Heimserver.
Schreibt uns in die Kommentare, wie ihr eure Backups organisiert und ob ihr die Wiederherstellung schon mal getestet habt.
Und wenn euch solche Analysen gefallen, dann abonniert uns.
Mein Backup ist easy as fuck. Externe USB-Festplatte, nacht-nächtlich-Air-Sync fertig.
Abonniert gerne unseren Kanal. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao.
Wiederherstellungstests mache ich nicht. Ist mir zu anstrengend.
So wie wahrscheinlich die meisten Leute.
Mach dein Hardware-Rad.
Linux statt Windows.
Meine ehrliche Bilanz nach einem Jahr.
Okay.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Sommer-Gadgets.
Offenbach ist booming.
Oh je.
Gen Z in Frankfurts Finanzbranche.
erfolg um jeden preis vor 32 minuten angucken ist übrigens aufgefallen dass
ich tabs geschlossen habe sieht man dass ich habe bestimmt 30 tabs von morgen zu
gemacht er kann jetzt fast wieder was erkennen
aber zum glück habe ich hier noch ein paar und hier noch ein paar
Ich benutze die eh nicht.
Machen wir die runter.
Mach die alle zu.
Nee, warum?
Da sind ja Sachen drin, die ich mir nur angucken will.
Kann ich einfach alle zumachen.
Zieh.
Die waren morgen auch schon wieder da hier.
Und hat ihr morgendliche Opfergabe abgegriffen.
Ne, Mikrowelle ist er nicht an.
Aber ich guck mal kurz.
Aber das ist glaube ich ein bisschen zu früh für Mikrowelle.
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
ne ne ne
das Mikro wälzt sich noch nix
so was haben wir denn sonst noch schönes hier zu bieten
Linux statt Windows
meine ehrlich ich bin ganz zu einem ja okay
vielleicht springen wir mal ein bisschen
vor und so mal gucken
ob das Video
interesting ist
ihr kennt ja meine Sicht
der Dinge ich bin der Meinung
man sollte einfach das System benutzen,
jeweils, was sich am besten eignet
für das, was man machen will.
Deswegen habe ich hier meinen Linux und da meinen Windows.
Das heißt, irgendwelche Sachen für
Videos, Thumbnails, Gaming
mache ich unter Windows, alles andere mache ich unter Linux.
Ganz einfach.
Und ich kann das auch easy umschalten
dazwischen. Also insofern, ich benutze
einfach das Beste
aus beiden Welten.
Jetzt exklusiv auf Linux.
Ich spiele, ich arbeite, ich mache die ganzen YouTube Sachen hier auf Linux und das ist
ein bisschen Zeit, einfach mal drauf zu gucken, was finde ich denn geil, was finde ich nicht
so geil und würde ich zurückgehen zu Windows?
Hm, finden wir raus.
Ich habe mir drei Teile überlegt, in die ich so reingehe.
Und zwar den ersten Teil, da gucken wir ein bisschen drauf,
was finde ich denn eigentlich richtig geil, was macht mir richtig viel Spaß unter Linux.
Und der zweite Teil.
Ja gut, .NET Framework funktioniert unter Linux nicht gescheit.
Du kannst mit Wine da ein bisschen was versuchen, aber das ist natürlich eklig.
Das sackt halt, wenn man noch .NET Windows Desktop Only Anwendungen hat.
.NET Framework wohlgemerkt.
dort netz selbst ist ja unter linux super mittlerweile aber dort netz framework sagt halt
beteiligt schon ein bisschen was mich so richtig ab im sinne von so funktioniert nicht und ich
muss irgendwie alles von vorne machen und dass ich muss irgendwie neu denken und bla bla und
der dritte teil ist dann so richtig fazit ist es jetzt das bleibe ich hier oder habe ich dann doch
mal vielleicht irgendwie den switch wieder richtung windows geplant wir hätten sehen
wir gehen direkt in den ersten teil rein was ist denn so richtig geil für mich unter linux
was gefällt microsoft chat denn so richtig seitdem ich linux so jeden tag benutze und damit spiele
und arbeite spielen vor allen dingen das ist halt was eine ganz großes wort das ist halt das was
richtig wahnsinnig viel spaß macht finde ich inzwischen walf und proton sind hier die absoluten
retter für diese linux gaming szene wenn es das nicht gebe dann werden wir ganz schön gearscht
das wissen wir es glaube ich irgendwie geht ich benutze es hier seit einem halben jahr oder so
wie lange wann haben wir das installiert halbes jahr überhaupt keine probleme mit funktioniert
wunderbar ja und von daher das ist halt wirklich schön zu sehen wie toll es inzwischen funktioniert
wie viele patches da kommen dass spiele auch schnell gepatcht werden auch nach dem erscheinen
selbst wenn sie im Early Access sind oder wenn sie am Launch-Tag ein bisschen fummelig laufen,
da kann man fast die Uhr nachts stellen. Nach zwei, drei Tagen hat man da einen Patch in der Leitung,
der dann auch halt das Spiel unter Linux ziemlich gut lauffähig macht. Und das ist schon echt
faszinierend, das hätte es vor ein paar Jahren noch nicht gegeben. Das ist halt ein großes Ding,
wo ich sage so, wow, und so knapp 90 Prozent meiner Library unter Steam läuft auch so ohne
großes Zutun unter Linux. Auch Spiele, die mit über Good Old Games kommen, die man in DOSBox
konfigurieren muss oder die dann auch die und zwei das ist auch uraltes geld sei früher auch
gespielt automatisch konfiguriert werden über das doch jemand das ist strategie spiel gewesen
eines der ersten zur echtzeit strategie spiele die geologie installer und sowas schafft alles
so toll und einwandfrei über wine schrägstrich proton das ist halt echt ein riesen riesen plus
und macht einfach wahnsinnig viel freude muss man ganz klar sagen und auch hier so ein bisschen so
wie ich dazu gekommen bin auch früher also schon hätte schon vor diesem switch jetzt vor einem jahr
vor diesem full time switch auf die noch schon sehr viel berührung mit gaming unter linux also
mein erstes projekt mit dem ich wieder eingestiegen bin vor ein paar jahren war hier so ein raspberry
pi der steckt hier drin so was bei drei steckt hier drin als emulation konsole mit so einem
kleinen gehäuse dann gekauft und hier eingebaut ich ganz süß also der läuft auch heute noch wenn
ich jetzt anschließen würde per die könnte ich den hier starten und könnte darauf irgendwelche
konsolen dinge spielen mit retropie ist da quasi draußen der linux distribution die speziell für
der raspberry pi es war um halt so retrospiele zu emulieren das hat sich erste berührungspunkt
wo ich wieder eingestiegen bin und wieder so ein bisschen gelernt habe und natürlich viele andere
projekte außenrum alles was hat dann mit den ganzen umstiegsgeschichten und dann halt dann
distribution ausprobiert auch so klein mini pc ist und dann immer wieder die distribution getauscht
und andere erfahrungen gemacht und schon schön also auch was man da alles dabei lernt ist halt
echt ein absoluter Knaller und das ist auch mein zweiter richtig positiver Punkt mit Linux. Man
lernt einfach unfassbar viel, wie Computer funktionieren, wie Computer starten, wie Computer
Informationen verarbeiten, wie die ganze Hardware miteinander funktioniert, wie USB funktioniert,
wie Grafikkarten funktionieren, wie Prozessoren funktionieren. Da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
sagen, dass man das mit Linux wirklich lernt. Man lernt vor allem mit Linux den Umgang mit Linux und
es kommt ja immer wieder im Stream die Frage, wie lernt man denn am besten Linux? Und da sage ich,
ja, halt benutzen täglich.
Das ist das Beste, was ihr machen könnt.
Sei es in der VM auf einem extra Mini-PC,
Dual-Boot würde ich nicht unbedingt dazu raten,
aber ein Mini-PC in der eigenen
oder eben in der Vmware-Workstation,
das ist ja mittlerweile kostenlos,
in der VM installiert,
dann habt ihr ein funktionierendes Windows,
auf dem ihr alles machen könnt,
wenn es mal wirklich drauf ankommt,
und Linux und einfach versuchen,
tagtägliche Arbeit unter Linux zu erledigen.
Da lernt man den Umgang mit Linux.
Ja, da lernt man standardmäßig
die defaultsachen auf der command-zeile man lernt seine distribution besser kennen man lernt wo es
verschiedene config dateien gibt was für settings gibt alles mögliche welche packages denn jetzt
einem gefallen als programm welche nicht und linux einfach täglich benutzen ist das beste was man
machen kann alles dinge die man so nebenbei ein bisschen mit saugt wenn man nicht mit linux
beschäftigt und den ganzen einzelnen systemen warum nicht dual boot weil dann die hürde zu
zu groß ist. Also erstens kannst du dir was kaputt
machen mit Dual Boot, je nachdem was du da
überlaufen hast. Und
viel ist dann die Hürde zu groß
nach Linux zu booten. Die sagen dann
ah, ich muss manchmal auf Windows
spielen und das funktioniert.
Dann bleibe ich gleich auf Windows.
Ich finde es am besten, also wenn Dual
Boot, wenn überhaupt,
dann auf einer zweiten SSD.
Dass man sich nichts kaputt macht.
Aktuell habe ich noch gar kein NAS im Einsatz.
Die stehen hier immer noch rum, die drei.
Also ich bin kein Fan von Dual Boot. Und ich bin auch, weil es jetzt gleich kommt, warum nicht einfach Windows unter Linux laufen lassen? Ich bin auch kein Fan von GPU-Pass through Windows VM.
Da hast du ja dann die Nachteile von allem gepaart, ja. Übelst kompliziert, gerade für Einsteiger. Probleme mit manchen Games, die nicht laufen. Plus du brauchst ein extra Setup aus Monitor und Tastatur, wenn du Pech hast. Also, ne.
Oder du brauchst sowas wie Looking Glass und dann hast du wieder ein Frame Delay und regst dich bei Competitive Games drüber auf, dass du gekillt wurdest, was bestimmt an diesem einen Frame liegt. Das ist Mist. Wie gesagt, ich mag weder Windows unter Linux laufen lassen, noch mag ich Dual Boot. Was mir persönlich am besten gefällt ist zwei Rechner, so wie ich das hier auch habe, eine Windows Kiste, eine Linux Kiste. Das ist für mich am besten.
was ich auch gut finde ist windows und darauf vor allem der workstation mit einem linux man
kann es ja mittlerweile auf verschiedenen desktops laufen lassen unter windows auch
gar kein problem funktioniert wunderbar das finde ich persönlich am besten die also die
die für mich jetzt beste lösung ist allerdings tatsächlich linux mini pc hier guck hier habe
ich ein Linux Mini PC mit
wo ist es denn hier?
8 Kerne, 8 Kerne Ryzen
und irgendeine Mobile Graphics
Card von AMD.
Das Ding hat wirklich jetzt nicht super krass Power,
aber ist schon
CPU-technisch nicht schlecht.
8 GB RAM habe ich übrigens auch aktuell
nur drin. Oder gar nur 7,
weil die Grafikkarte ein bisschen was braucht.
Und für alles andere
habe ich hier meine fette Windows-Kiste
mit
weiß ich gar nicht, wie viele Kerne
habe ich denn?
Sieht man das da irgendwo?
Hier, 24
Kern und 64 GB
und 4090 RTX.
Und ich
benutze in der Regel, zum
größten Teil benutze ich mittlerweile
die Linux-Kiste,
aber zum Streamen, für
irgendwelche Gaming-Sachen benutze ich einfach weiterhin Windows.
Das ist
für mich
Beste Kombination aus beiden Welten
Wie benutzt du deine Hardware gleichzeitig bei beiden PCs?
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche PCs
Das ist ein Linux Mini PC
Und das ist hier mein Windows Desktop PC
Achso
Du meinst das Umswitchen
Die Tastatur und so
Okay das ist ein bisschen komplizierter
Das habe ich schon öfters erzählt im Stream
Aber die Frage kommt immer
Ich erkläre es nochmal
Das ist wirklich echt ein bisschen komplizierter.
Also, das sieht folgendermaßen aus.
Folgendermaßen habe ich das gemacht.
Also, guck mal hier.
Du kannst unter Windows mehrere Desktops haben.
Desktop 1, Desktop 2, Desktop 3.
So.
Desktop schaltet man unter Windows durch mit
Ctrl, Windows-Taste, Pfeiltaste rechts, Pfeiltaste links.
So, und du siehst, guck mal hier.
Ich bin jetzt hier unter Windows, nicht unter Linux.
Und du siehst, das ist auch nur ein OBS auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Also mein Linux ist eigentlich nur ein OBS im Fullscreen.
Guck da, Windows, hier Linux.
Das ist ein OBS im Fullscreen.
So, der Mini-PC geht an eine Elgato Capture Card dran.
Das leckt nicht.
Das ist eine Elgato Capture Card, 240 Hertz, 1080p.
Und das hat nahezu keinen Leck.
da geht sowohl da geht sowieso und als auch video drüber und das ist wirklich das ist im
normalen desktop betrieb komplett lag frei ich würde jetzt da keine competitive games
auf spielen aber wir haben es mal ausprobiert wir haben reaktionstest gemacht unter windows
hatte ich irgendwie 160 millisekunden reaktionszeit unterlinux hatte ich keine 175 millisekunden
reaktionszeit 15 millisekunden das ist im desktop betrieb überhaupt kein ding und gar kein problem
Aber kannst du dann auch unter Linux mehrere Bildschirme verwenden?
Ne.
Warum nicht über RDP?
Das würde theoretisch auch funktionieren.
Aber ich will ja gerade Native Sachen auch mit GPU-Beschleunigung und sowas da benutzen.
Und dann wird es da schon wieder ein bisschen laggy über RDP.
RDP ist gut für statische Sachen.
Für alles andere jetzt weniger geil.
Ja, ich kann hier nicht mehrere Monitore verwenden.
Theoretisch würde es auch gehen, ja.
Da bräuchte ich aber zwei Capture Cards.
Das wäre dann irgendwie blödsinnig.
Ja, so.
und
genau, zwei Capture Cards.
Theoretisch gehen wird das ja. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Aber das
muss nicht sein. Mein zweiter Monitor
ist für Stream, Vorschau und Chat und alles.
So, und Maus und Tastatur.
Ihr seht ja hier, Maus und Tastatur geht hier auch.
Du kannst ja auch mal
Sunshine und Moonlight. Habe ich schon
getestet. Haben wir sogar im Stream gemacht.
Geht prinzipiell auch ganz
gut. Hatte aber Probleme.
Hatte Soundprobleme.
Copy-Paste ging nicht richtig.
Das hatte ein paar Usability-Probleme.
Ich habe das ausprobiert schon.
Deswegen bin ich hier auf OBS und Capture Card gelandet.
Ja, und wie das mit der Maus und Tastatur funktioniert, ist im Prinzip ganz einfach.
Ich habe hier sowas laufen, das nennt sich Deskflow.
Deskflow ist eine Software, mit der du Maus und Tastatur sharen kannst.
und wenn ich hierüber switche auf den zweiten desktop drückt im hintergrund
den makro in meiner logitech software das umschalten trigger das umschalten
in des flow cook hier habe ich auch des flow laufen des flow und maus und tastatur sharing
funktioniert darüber ich könnte ja noch das makro zeigen und sonst wie aber jetzt guckt
wenn ich hier drin bin ich kann das von hand drücken ist wirklich alt dann ist das ein kommando
an an desk flow auch windows umzuschalten seht ihr das bild jetzt wieder den windows maus zeigt
wirklich bin ich wieder auf linux und das macht halt mal marco hier automatisch mit desktop switch
hast du das setup in dem geht das ist alles im grie zusammengeklickt und im obs und so ich glaube
Da kann man in Gitnix einchecken.
Ne.
Es ist nicht kompliziert.
Es ist nicht wirklich kompliziert.
Man braucht halt eine Capture Card für.
Und man braucht halt am besten eine PCI Express Capture Card
mit 240 Hertz.
Das heißt eine Auflösung,
die man in 240 Hertz capturen kann
und halt eine Capture Card,
die 240 Hertz kann.
Und am besten halt eine PCI Express Capture Card.
Weil so ist es halt kein Lack.
Es ist kein spürbarer Leck.
Die 15 Millisekunden jucken mich nicht.
Ich meine, guck mal.
Ups.
1 durch 60.
16 Millisekunden
ist ein Frame
bei 60 Hertz.
Ich habe ein Frame,
wenn man 60 Hertz nehmen würde.
Leck, quasi.
Aber ich habe ja 240 Hertz.
Also habe ich...
Okay, habe ich vier Frame Lags, okay.
Vier Frames.
Vier Frame Verzögerung bei 140 Hertz.
Das kann man echt verkraften.
Gut, jetzt gucken wir mal Video weiter.
Das System, wie die ineinander greifen, ist natürlich für Menschen, die technisch interessiert sind, eine absolute krasse Goldgrube.
Und das Hirn explodiert förmlich, weil man einfach wahnsinnig viele neue Sachen lernt.
für menschen die einfach nur aber heute mal ist okay das zeige ich noch schnell
gucke ich habe hier einfach in meiner logitech software habe ich in makro
auf f1 f2 und die machen im prinzip nichts anderes wie die drücken die
shortcuts in des flow alt ist switchen
Und ich muss das andere Makro zeigen.
Ja, das drückt linke Windows-Taste Control nach rechts.
Das heißt, es switcht rüber auf den zweiten Desktop.
Und dann drückt es Alt-A.
Alt-A ist umschalten auf die Maus in Deskflow.
Und zurück das gleiche halt in die andere Richtung und Alt-Ö für...
Welche Capture Card? Ich habe eine Elgato...
Okay...
Oh, wie heißt dieses Ding?
Elgato 4K Pro.
PC Express.
Das Ding, ja.
Das geht sicherlich auch mit anderen Capture Cards,
aber gerade wenn man nur 60 Hertz capturt
und wenn das Ganze noch per USB vielleicht sogar encoded wird,
dann hast du auf jeden Fall Lack.
Hier ist für mich im Desktopbetrieb kein Lack wirklich spürbar.
Auch nicht so schlimm, weil wenn ich das hier installiere und jemanden davor setze mit diesen ganzen neuen Distributionen und Desktopumgebungen, so wie Gnome oder KDE, da können auch Menschen einwandfrei mit Linux arbeiten, die sich mit Windows auskennen oder mit WebOS auskennen.
Ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass KDE geil ist und Gnome suckt.
Nach ein paar Klicks wissen die so ungefähr, wo sie hin müssen und erkennen die Begriffe.
Das ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Da sind wir schon auch sehr, sehr weit.
Und das ist auch wirklich ganz faszinierend.
Wie gesagt, was man da alles bei lernt, was man alles wieder irgendwie fühlt, was der eigene Computer kann, wie der eigene Computer reagiert, dass er wirklich nur das macht, was ich ihm sage.
Das ist schon echt lieb.
Das ist in der Tat unser Linux wirklich nice.
Da läuft halt im Hintergrund nicht 16 verschiedene oder 16, 30 verschiedene Dinger von Windows.
Wo du nicht weißt, wofür die da sind.
Wobei unter Linux natürlich auch Sachen im Hintergrund laufen, die man nicht selbst gestartet hat.
Zum Beispiel NTP-Client oder sowas. Aber es war bei weitem nicht in diesem Umfang und so undurchsichtig wie unter Windows.
Richtig schön und das ist ein Riesenplus meines Erachtens. Also dieser ganze Lerneffekt, der sich darum dreht.
Das ist schon wirklich ganz, ganz großartig. Und ich muss auch sagen, und das ist meine persönliche Erfahrung,
auch so ein tolles Ding, was ich wirklich richtig schön finde, ist die Community rund um Linux,
zumindest so wie ich sie erfahren habe, ob es jetzt in Foren ist. Das kommt drauf an,
wo man unterwegs ist. Bei Cache, bei Debian. Er könnte mal in das Mikrocontroller-Forum gehen,
da ist die Community auch ganz toll, habe ich gehört. Bei Fedora, wenn ich da unterwegs
gewesen bin vor vielen, vielen Monaten, vielen Jahren oder jetzt auch die Community, die sich
hier um den Kanal rundherum bildet, also alles, was in den Kommentaren hier passiert, was auf
in unserem Discord-Server passiert, wenn wir uns da unterhalten.
Ich muss wirklich sagen, alles nette Leute.
Ich habe bis jetzt niemanden dabei gehabt, der irgendwie rumgestenkt hat.
Wenn, dann haben wir irgendwie angeregt miteinander diskutiert
und sind da ganz vernünftig geblieben und haben Argumente ausgetauscht.
Finde ich super. Das war auch mal anders.
Da geht so ein bisschen die Community, geht so ein bisschen voran.
Man hat so einen kleinen Schritt nach vorne gemacht.
Man fängt an, sich nicht gegenseitig irgendwie zu beleidigen oder so.
Kommt drauf an, wo.
Man ist dabei, aktiv dabei, man diskutiert und tauscht die Meinungen aus.
und das ist auch ganz schön, dass man da inzwischen ein bisschen inklusiver ist und Leute nicht einfach nur irgendwie abschottet
und hier sagt so, zack, hier ist ein Tor, da kommt keiner mehr rein, das ist ja Linux, da wollen wir andere Menschen nicht drin haben,
sondern man macht das Törchen so ein bisschen auf, Leute kommen rein, lernen was, man kann was erklären.
Das ist ja auch mein Teil hier auf diesem YouTube-Kanal.
Ich will ja, dass Menschen was lernen, ich will ja, dass Menschen verstehen und sehen, guck mal, das kann man einfach so einsetzen,
man kann das wirklich jeden Tag.
Ja, Gnome-Entwickler sind auch sehr nette Leute, habe ich gehört.
arbeiten. Man kann damit spielen,
man kann damit Sachen machen. Und das ist
halt das, was hier der Kanal auch so ein bisschen beweisen soll
auf Dauer. Einfach zu sehen,
ach cool, guck mal, kann man einfach
installieren. Und das ist echt wirklich ganz
hervorragend. Und wer ein bisschen Bock
auf hier so Linux Circle Jerk
hat, der kann sich ja mal ein paar
Wayland Diskussionen
durchlesen.
Ich mag's und das muss ich
sagen, ist mit der
schönste, größte Vorteil, den ich hier
in diesem einen Jahr Linux so erlebt habe.
Was nervt mich denn jetzt nach einem Jahr Linux,
das jeden Tag benutzen und auch professionell benutzen,
hier für den YouTube-Kanal, für Videoschnitt und für Gaming
und für die ganzen sonstigen Sachen, die ich halt so tue?
Da muss ich sagen, man merkt, dass wir an der Applikationsfront
noch echt viel, viel vor uns haben.
Das ist halt so richtig toll, dass es halt Open Source Software gibt,
die schön funktioniert, die die meisten Fälle in normaler Benutzerschaft
auch einwandfrei abdecken kann.
Da muss man gar nicht so weit suchen.
Sobald es in eine etwas professionellere Richtung geht und man ein bisschen mehr Anspruch hat,
dann brechen diese Open Source Geschichten relativ schnell in sich zusammen oder da
fehlen einfach wichtige Features oder sind inkompatibel zu anderen Sachen.
Das ist halt schon so ein Phänomen, das halt irgendwie sehr, sehr intensiv auftritt.
Bei mir zum Beispiel gerade hauptsächlich in Kdenlive, in dieser Video-Editing-Software,
die eigentlich ziemlich gut ist und echt viele Features hat.
Ja gut, es gibt ja auch noch DaVinci Resolve für Linux.
Da bin ich auch so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen, weil ich habe es ja installiert.
Als ich es installiert habe, hat es noch funktioniert, bilde ich mir ein.
Aber jetzt funktioniert es aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht mehr.
Und ich weiß nicht warum.
Jetzt geht es wieder nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung, was es jetzt hat.
Jetzt habe ich es geskippt und weiter, jetzt ist es kaputt.
Toll.
Also, naja.
Ich merke einfach, so im professionellen Zusammenarbeiten mit anderen, da fällt es ja manchmal hinten
runter im Export, im Import von irgendwelchen Dingen.
Und das ist halt schon so ein Ding, wo man sagt, da hätte ich gern was professionelleres.
Da Vinci Resolve gibt es für Linux auch.
Aber da ist die Installation wirklich so unfassbar krass kompliziert und funktioniert ganz oft auf regulären Distributionen gar nicht.
Das ist schon echt doof, dass man das nicht einfach so installieren kann und benutzen kann.
Hätte ich wahrscheinlich gemacht, hätte ich wahrscheinlich sogar gekauft für die paar hundert Euro, weil ich es professionell hier anwenden möchte.
Aber das ist halt echt ein richtiger Kampf aktuell. Da hoffe ich, dass das mal irgendwann richtig funktioniert.
Was ich auch halt immer wieder mal so sehe, sind Dinge, die mit Wayland zu tun haben.
Wayland ist ein Display-Server-Protokoll unter Linux.
Das hat Wayland, ist ein Thema für sich, ja.
Das X11-Protokoll abgelöst, das ist schon richtig, richtig alt, aus den 70ern noch.
Und Wayland ist ein bisschen neuer, das gibt es seit 2008,
schrägstrich 2012 ist die erste Version 1.0, ist da richtig offiziell erschienen.
Und das kümmert sich im Wesentlichen um Fensterdarstellung
und wie Programme miteinander kommunizieren,
wie Programme ihre Inhalte in Fenstern darstellen,
also bei Spielen, Anwendungssoftware und so weiter.
Und da gibt es echt so ein paar ganz kuriose Geschichten,
die immer noch nicht ausgebügelt sind. Also sowas wie HDR, VAA, also so variable Refresh-Rates und so weiter,
sind immer noch Probleme, es sind immer noch so Dinge, die haken.
Vor allen Dingen, es gibt Dinge wie unter Wayland, dass bestimmte Eingaben von speziellen Tastaturen
oder wenn so Tastaturen auch so Media-Knöpfe halt haben, Lautstärkeregler oder sowas.
AuraXio, das ist genauso wie bei SystemD, da gibt es ja auch noch welche, die immer schreiben, hier SystemD muss weg.
dass sie eine krasse Verzögerung vor allen Dingen unter KDE haben. Das habe ich hier zum Beispiel
mit meiner Keychron-Tastatur auch, mit diesem Volume-Knob, den ich hier oben habe, mit diesem
kleinen Regler, den ich hier drehen kann. Das hat einfach eine wahnsinnige Verzögerung unter Wayland,
warum auch immer, wenn ich KDE benutze. Wenn ich GNOME benutze, die Desktop-Umgebung,
dann funktioniert es einwandfrei, witzigerweise. Ja gut, das liegt daran, weil Wayland ja nur
quasi eine spezifikation ist und jeder den kram selbst implementiert bei x ist es ja
wie soll ich also gibt es ja viele teile die gemeinsam genutzt werden das heißt bei
x ist einfach alles überall kaputt wenn es kaputt ist und bei weyland geht es halt unter
manchen umgebungen und der manchen implementieren unter manchen nicht was mit kt zu tun man weiß
dass es eine geschichte ist zwischen kd und zwischen wayland das muss irgendwie gefixt
werden bis da die parteien zusammenkommen und das irgendwie mal so richtig fixen können wir
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern das ist halt immer ein bisschen nervig dass man da auch
dass man auch ein bisschen warten muss bis sachen gefixt werden das könnte man theoretisch hingehen
und sagen so wieso du kannst auch hingehen und selber was bei steuern und was tun ja kann auch
nicht jeder das wird ja immer so gesagt das ist ja das tolle an open source ich behaupte einfach
90 Prozent der Leute sind gar nicht wirklich in der Lage, bei den meisten Projekten sinnvoll,
Source-Code-mäßig was zu kontributen.
Ja, du kannst dich anderweitig beteiligen, aber versuch mal zu KDE was zu kontributen,
was sinnvoll ist, wenn du keine Ahnung davon hast.
Ich bin auch irgendwie sehr aktiv da und stelle da auch Fehlerberichte ein und so weiter
und schaue, dass ich da auf dem Laufenden bleibe.
Ja, das kannst du machen, genau.
Was alles aktualisiert wird, was in der Neueren wird.
Foronix ist auch so ein schönes Ding, wo in den Kommentaren auch immer richtig, richtig nette Leute nur sind.
Versionen von Wayland oder von bestimmten Komponenten, was da auf den Tisch kommt, um so ein bisschen das Gefühl zu haben, wo hat sich jetzt was geändert, wo kann man nochmal ein bisschen mehr Komfort erwarten oder wie auch immer.
Das schon, aber es sind Kinderkrankheiten, aber die können so in einem richtigen Workflow,
wenn man den halt hat.
Und wenn man einfach nur arbeiten möchte oder einfach nur spielen möchte, sind da
Dinge dabei, wo einfach ganz schnell kleinere Dinge einfach super krass nerven können.
Und das ist halt schon so.
Das habe ich jetzt in diesem Jahr immer wieder erliest.
Und was ich auch immer wieder mal habe, ist tatsächlich die Hardware, die ich verwende,
die ich per USB anschließe, dass da Sachen dabei sind, die einfach nicht sofort funktionieren.
Zum Beispiel so einen kleinen Jog Shuttle, mit dem ich halt auch dann den Videoschnitt
ein bisschen halt mache und klar das ist jetzt keine super teure marke das ist so ein ding von
amazon für 20.000 euro sollte man vielleicht nicht so viel erwarten aber theoretisch einfach
nur usb den weist das bestimmte funktion nach außen halt öffnet und dann muss man es eigentlich
ansprechen können funktioniert nicht out of the box unter linux muss man damit irgendwelchen
komischen regeln und irgendwelchen der drehen nach patchen im system damit es erkannt wird
damit es funktioniert wenn es dann funktioniert ist irgendwie halt sein aber trotzdem das sind
standard sachen das müsste eigentlich funktionieren ich steckst rein und dann sollte das bitte da sein
das ist ein bisschen seltsam manchmal ja auch der frege dann kannst du keinen loslassen das
komplette verwirrung sowas wie hierbei der pdk kron tastatur hier ein firmware update zu machen
über die webseite das ist ein service der über die webseite geht bei key kronen wo man sich
einbild und dann hat sagt so hier ist man hier ist mein keyboard einfach mit dem kabel anschließen
und dann müsste das normalerweise das erkennen kurz auch nicht unter linux das muss man wenn
ja wahrscheinlich weil der usb support nicht richtig funktioniert vom browser es gibt auch
jetzt so ein so so web usb oder wie das heißt oder web bluetooth und so kann durchaus sein dass das
nicht funktioniert unter linux dann unter mac os machen oder unter windows in der windows wm
geht's wenn man der windows wm aufruft und dann das gerät durch schleift über den entsprechenden
haken dann kann man plötzlich die firmware aktualisieren die lichter einstellen sie
realistische konfiguration abspeichern genau irgendwie ein bisschen beherrschte dass sie
nicht und das ist unter linux in dem normalen browser nicht funktioniert es gibt workaround
aber auch hier wieder standard funktion sorry bitte das hat doch irgendwie müssen sie funktionieren
gibt es auch leute die das irgendwie schon gefixt haben aber auf großer breiter front sind das immer
wieder so kleinigkeiten die so hängen bleiben die so ein bisschen so dem flow stören wo man sich so
ein bisschen denkt so schritt 20 wieder irgendwie ein workaround suchen oder irgendjemanden fragen
in foren gucken oder meine ki anschmeißen und fragen was da irgendwie phase ist das ist halt
schon so ein bisschen nervig aber das sind so die die die dinge die mich am meisten nerven muss ich
gestehen größere baustellen was jetzt irgendwie software betrifft was jetzt spiele betrifft und
so weiter sich da also ich da persönlich persönlich jetzt gerade aktuell tatsächlich
nicht auch die sache mit anti cheat ja natürlich irgendwie super nervig dass es bestimmte antik
spieler und verhindern es nicht so auch ohne weiteres gibt dass man da noch warten muss aber
die bewegung gibt es ja habe ich jetzt auch schon mehrfach erwähnt dass er gerade elektronik arzt
dabei ist zum beispiel den eigenen antizid auf die nutzer zu bringen also das sind so
So die Bewegungen, die gerade drin sind, wo man vielleicht in den nächsten Monaten ein bisschen Besserung erwarten kann.
Epic Games ist auch mit dabei, die wollen auch ihren Anti-Cheat auf Linux ziehen.
Und das ist schon eine gute Bewegung.
Ja, das stimmt.
Und da können sich Sachen noch umso mehr, umso besser.
Die da wieder ganz positiv irgendwie sind.
Im Moment ist es aber halt noch ein Ärgernis.
Kann man nicht spielen, wenn man sowas unbedingt spielen möchte, wie Fortnite, Battlefield und Dröht.
Dann muss man halt auf jeden Fall das 11 wechseln.
So ist es halt.
Aber jetzt Mutter bei die Fische.
Habe ich es jetzt bereut, auf Linux ein Jahr lang komplett nur so zu arbeiten und zu spielen?
Oder würde ich jetzt zurück auf Windows gehen, weil ich Linux irgendwie doof finde?
Nee, natürlich nicht. Das ist wahrscheinlich schon relativ offensichtlich.
Natürlich werde ich auf Linux bleiben, allein schon, weil das mir persönlich einfach wahnsinnig viel Spaß macht,
weil ich damit extrem viel lerne.
Natürlich, weil es auch die Basis für diesen Kanal hier ist, muss man ganz klar sagen.
Das hat sich jetzt positiv daraus ergeben, dass ich durch das ganze Wissen, das ich halt habe,
das auch weitergeben möchte und das mit euch teilen möchte.
ist natürlich wunderschön, dass man das miteinander
verbinden kann und wieder zusammen auch halt lernen
können und auch andere Leute hier reinkommen und sagen so
wow, krass, ich hab da was gelernt und ich mach das
auch so und ich hab meine Lieblingsspiele
wieder zum Laufen gebracht, weil ich hier den Kanal geguckt
habe. Das sind wundervolle, großartige
Dinge, die sich jetzt so ergeben und natürlich
haben wir noch viel zu tun, wir müssen noch viel
miteinander uns angucken, wir haben noch
ganz, ganz viele Themen auf der Spur.
Ich kann jetzt schon mal spoilern, das wird nie
aufhören.
Du hast immer irgendwas zu basteln,
zu tweaken, zu machen. Das ist ja auch das schöne an Linux.
Und natürlich wird das alles mit Linux passieren.
Das ist mein Plan und das wird auch so bleiben.
Privat werde ich es auch weiterhin absolut verwenden,
von meinen ganzen privaten Dingen, die ich halt...
Aber es macht ja auch Spaß unter Linux.
Unter Windows fuckt mich das immer ab, wenn ich da irgendwas machen muss.
Und in Linux kann ich drei Stunden am Stück basteln.
Und freue mich dann, weil ich irgendwie jetzt
CPU-Auslastung-Anzeige in der Taskbar habe oder so.
Ja, Anti-Cheat ist das, also was Spiele,
wohlgemerkt, wenn wir uns mal nur auf Spiele
beschränken, was da
der größte Knackpunkt ist, ist tatsächlich Anti-Cheat.
Wenn man da was spielen will, Rainbow Six
oder sowas spielen will. Das ist ohnehin
schon komplett isoliert von allem anderen, was ich halt so tue,
beruflich und privat. Das ist bei privaten
Linux 100%ig. Beruflich werde ich wahrscheinlich
auch zu 90, 95%
unter Linux unterwegs sein in den nächsten Monaten.
Auch irgendwie sehr schön.
Und das wird auch so bleiben.
Da habe ich absolut gar keinen Wunsch, auf Windows zurückzukehren, da irgendwas zu machen.
Ich bin immer wieder so ein bisschen erstaunt von den Dingen, die teilweise Windows meldet,
wenn ich hier so ein bisschen Supportarbeit für meine Frau auf dem Windows 11 Rechner machen muss,
wenn da mal wieder Timer-Updates fällig sind und so weiter.
Da merkt man schon, dass Linux echt viele Vorteile hat, auch gerade bei System-Updates,
wo viele Sachen einfach mehr oder weniger automatisch funktionieren, wenn man es so einstellt.
Das ist schon echt schön, muss man sagen.
Alter, was hat denn da für ein abgedrehtes Terminal am Start?
viele Sachen einfach mehr oder weniger automatisch funktionieren,
wenn man es so einstellt.
Was ist das?
Jemand eine Idee? Mit dieser Eule?
Das ist schon echt schön, muss man sagen.
Das macht schon echt Spaß.
Deswegen überhaupt keine Ambition,
wieder mit Windows 11 irgendwas zu machen.
Es sei denn, es muss unbedingt sein,
wegen dem Spiel, das unter anderem nicht funktioniert.
Ja, das ist Shelley.
Aber das Terminal,
was das Terminal ist.
Oder in meiner Familie gerade groß angesagt ist,
dass man da nicht so komplett
außen vor ist.
Aber Kitty hat doch nicht so eine Eule als Logo.
Aber für alles andere keine Chance.
Ich bleibe bei Linux. Das ist
mein Arbeitsstil. Das ist halt genau das, was ich
gerne möchte. So habe ich das immer gelernt.
So habe ich das auch in jungen Jahren
mit C64, Amiga und so weiter
immer gelernt, dass die Computer
auch halt das machen, was ich halt möchte und
was ich ihnen sage und da ist Linux einfach das Maß der Dinge. Das kann man nicht anders formulieren, meines Erachtens.
Deswegen, ich habe damit wahnsinnig viel Spaß. Ich teile meine Eindrücke wahnsinnig gern, auch halt vor allen Dingen natürlich mit euch über diesen YouTube-Kanal.
Das war nicht dieses Logo.
Und natürlich, das ist das Thema, was ich noch gar nicht angesprochen habe, was aber durchaus mal ein Thema sein kann auf dem Kanal.
Was jetzt mal abgesehen vom Spielen und das hier jeden Tag benutzen und damit halt arbeiten mit Linux.
Natürlich fallen da auch ganz viele andere Sachen noch runter, im Sinne von Homelabbing zum Beispiel.
ja gut das hat jetzt nichts mit ja gut aber die negativpunkte kann ich voll nachvollziehen sie auch
so vollkommen nachvollziehbar
face it also ich habe mal ein bisschen fest gespielt zu zeiten als noch cs gespielt habe
und da hast du da brauchst ja so eine extra software von denen genauso wie
damals für die esl wenn du wenn du auf der watch in der esl spielen wollte das
hast du so einen so einen esl so eine komische esl klein software gebraucht
richtig ranzig ist zwingend dinge
wie heißt der kanal von dem video und
so auf
wird dirk
das sei ein jahr lang bin ich jetzt exklusiv auf die nux
sie sind geek
der dirk 74 wo er das noch älter als ich denke immer schon ich bin alt
Oh, ich krieg Hunger.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was die Mikrowelle macht.
Äh.
OKS?
Warum startet mein Home Assistant nicht?
Home Assistant.
Oh, gleich gibt es was zu essen.
Pogu.
20 Minuten oder so, vermute ich.
Vielleicht gibt es was.
Excellent, excellent.
Lass uns doch grad mal
Wo ich grad gesagt hab hier
Von wegen Foren
Wo nervige Leute unterwegs sind
Lass uns doch grad mal kurz reingucken
Ich will gar nichts großartiges
Ich will nur mal
Gucken was hier der aktuelle
Das aktuelle Circle Jerk Thema ist
Bei Microcontroller Forum
Wo gehen wir da hin
Microcontroller
Also ich zeig dieses Forum hier immer gerne
Weil das das Leute
Das ist das schlimmste, abgefuckteste Kackforum, was es gibt.
Ich glaube, so kann man das sagen.
Elektronik für Anfänger.
Das klingt wie ein schönes Topic vom Mikrocontroller-Forum, wo sie sich alle gegenseitig abfacken.
Es geht schon gut los.
Guck mal, es geht schon gut los.
Hallo, wo kann man im Netz Elektronik lernen?
Zum Beispiel YouTube, wo gibt es gute, kostenlose Seiten?
Wenn du die nicht selbst...
Moment, was?
Wenn du die nicht selbst zum Finden entstanden bist,
solltest du mit so etwas Komplizierter wie Elektronik gar nicht erst anfangen.
Die Leute sind einfach immer so nett in diesem Forum, ja?
So nice.
Ich glaube, hier gibt es auch viele Leute, die der Meinung sind, dass man außer Assembler nichts anderes braucht.
Wahrscheinlich geht es hier unten richtig dumm schon zur Sache.
Die Leute, Alter.
Das Forum ist wirklich mit Abstand
das beschissenste Forum.
was es gibt.
Ja, weil,
wie gesagt, die sind auch der Meinung,
dass alles außer Assembler zu Highlevel ist.
Wisst ihr, was mich auch mal richtig krass genervt hat?
Also das hat jetzt gar nichts mit dummen Leuten im Forum zu tun oder so.
Ich bin mal mit meinem Fahrrad,
meinem Rose-Bike, also was ich im Internet bestellt habe,
bin ich mal in ein Fahrradgeschäft gefahren.
ehrlich gesagt, ich habe gar keine Ahnung
mehr, was ich da wollte.
Ich glaube, er wollte fragen,
was es kosten würde, wenn er mir das auf
Tubeless umstellt.
Hat mich damals einfach nur interessiert.
Ich weiß es, wirklich Leute, ich habe keine Ahnung mehr,
was ich eigentlich wollte in dem Fahrradgeschäft.
Ich kann mich nur noch an die Antwort von dem Typ erinnern.
Ich habe den gefragt,
ich habe den gefragt,
was ich den fragen wollte
und dann guckt er mich so an und sagt,
ah, ein Onliner.
Ja, das würden sie nicht machen.
Da hab ich erst mal blöd angeguckt, so, was will
der jetzt eigentlich von mir? Was will er mir
sagen?
Der wollte niemand bedienen, der das Fahrrad
online gekauft hat.
Ja gut, dann kriegst du halt kein Geld von mir. Pech. Tschüss.
CU.
WTF?
Ich mach eh fast alles selbst am Fahrrad.
Was auch besser ist,
weil wahrscheinlich sind die meisten Fahrradläden so dumm drauf.
Und dann, ja, und dann wird sich aufgeregt
Das sind die gleichen Läden, die sich drüber aufreden
So nach dem Motto, oh nein, der lokale Handel stirbt
Hier kommt ja keiner mehr zu uns
Max, welches Bike hast du?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad im Chat
Ich glaube, wir haben da einen Link
Zu Internet Archive
Ausrufezeichen Fahrrad, probier mal
Da müsstest du einen Link bekommen
Hinterhalb Archive und da müsstest du
Dann zu Rose gehen
Richtiger Offliner war das, ja
So dummes Gelaber, Alter
Ich kann das eh, ich krieg da
Komplette Anfälle, wenn ich
Ich bin da mittlerweile, ich hab da total dünne Haut, ja
Wenn ich in irgendeinen
Laden gehe
Und nur entfernt
irgendwas negatives gesagt wird, bin ich
immer sofort weg und die kriegen von mir kein
Geld.
Ja, also
wenn der Fahrradtyp irgendwas
über mein Fahrrad sagt, dass ich es online gekauft
habe, okay, tschüss.
Mir fällt jetzt leider kein anderes Beispiel
ein, aber das kommt öfters mal vor.
Dass mich Läden irgendwie belehren wollen oder
nerven wollen oder irgendwas.
hast du gesagt, okay, tschüss, kaufe ich nicht bei euch,
kaufe ich online.
Magst Fahrrad? Ja, genau, das hier ist es.
Das ist es,
Leute, das ist es.
Ein Rose Backroad GRX
X810
Di2.
Es ist auch noch
im Originalzustand,
das Einzige, was ich,
okay, kann man sich aufmachen, das Einzige, was ich geändert
habe, ist,
Hier hinten.
Die Kassette habe ich ausgetauscht.
Da ist eine 11 bis 34
standardmäßig drauf und ich habe eine 11 bis
40 oder
42. Bin mir nicht ganz sicher drauf gemacht.
Mario, danke schon für den Sub.
Pog Subscription.
Ganz ehrlich?
dann sollen sie den preis halt entsprechend machen die soll halt den preis entsprechend machen und
wenn ich nicht bezahlen bezahlt nicht also unser halt dem entspricht sollen sie halt entsprechend
was verlangen dafür können ich einfach immer nur sagen aber verdienen wir fast nicht dran
der nebenhalten ordentlichen preis für wenn sie so teuer ist geht halt nicht hin
Das würde ich sogar verstehen.
Das geht...
Ohne Scheiß.
Das würde ich sogar verstehen.
Wenn die sagen,
für Leute, die das Fahrrad bei uns gekauft haben,
ist es günstiger,
bekommst du 30% oder so.
Das würde ich voll und ganz verstehen.
Ich brauche kein Problem mit.
Ja, dann haben sie Pech.
Dann haben sie Pech.
Also, du kannst ja nicht das eine oder das andere haben.
Also, ich würde das machen lassen.
Also, mir ist die Zeit...
Also, gerade sowas, wie ich damals gedacht habe...
Ich habe nicht auf tubeless umgestellt,
aber ich habe mir das ernsthaft mal überlegt,
als ich viel gefahren bin.
Da habe ich gar keinen Bock, das selbst zu machen.
Wenn er clever ist,
wenn er clever ist,
hätte er mir vielleicht sogar einen neuen Laufradsatz
verkaufen können.
Wenn er gesagt hätte,
das alte kann man dann so behalten und wechseln.
wenn er clever gewesen wäre,
hätte er es vielleicht sogar geschafft.
Das ist der Eindruck, habe ich auch,
dass sie teilweise irgendwie gar kein Geld verdienen wollen.
Ich gehe jeden Tag laufen.
Und heute muss ich auch wieder.
Gestern war ich 1 Stunde 12, heute muss ich 46 Minuten.
Ich habe mir mittlerweile wieder Inlineskates gekauft, wo ich öfters fahre.
Und meinen Indoor-Trainer.
Ich fahre aktuell außen, also Outdoor-Bike, nicht so oft, weil es kaputt ist.
Und ich das Schaltauge wahrscheinlich mal wechseln müsste, weil es ein bisschen verbogen ist.
Nachdem ich da über einen sehr hupplichen Wegberg runtergefahren bin.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo hängen geblieben bin.
War ich bisher zu faul.
Da bin ich dann seit 2 Monaten schon zu faul zu.
Das ist überhaupt kein Akt
Das ist wirklich eine Sache von 10 Minuten
Ja, dann muss er sich halt nicht beschweren
Wenn die Leute bei ihm kein Geld ausgeben, ne
Ne, aber ich bin da mittlerweile total dünnhäutig
Sobald mir irgendein Typ
Also, wenn es darum geht, Geld auszugeben, ne
Sobald mir irgendeiner irgendwie
Ein bisschen dumm kommt
dreh ich instant wieder um und geh raus.
Ich diskutier mit denen schon gar nicht mehr.
Ich sag, oh, tschüss. Gar nicht.
Ja, kommst du in irgendeinen Laden rein,
sagst, ähm,
Frage, wo habt ihr denn XY stehen?
Und wenn dann irgendwie eine blöde Antwort kommt, so,
ja, da wo es immer steht, dann, tschüss.
Mach's gut.
Ich kauf woanders.
Das sehe ich nicht ein.
Ich bettel bei niemandem, Geld ausgeben zu dürfen.
Oh, Chat.
Chat, die Mikrowelle ist an.
Ich sehe es im Home Assistant.
Die Mikrowelle läuft.
Gleich gibt es Essen.
Hippo, Fat Time.
Fünf Minuten.
Bin ich off.
Wir müssen Set-Servers weitermachen.
Mir geht's wieder... Ach, by the way, wollte ich noch sagen, ne?
Haben ja letzte Woche so viel gesagt.
Gut, besser. Mir geht's wieder viel besser.
Und wisst ihr, was noch viel nicer ist?
Also mir geht's ja letztes Wochenende nicht so gut.
Wieder viel besser.
Wisst ihr, was richtig nice ist?
Ich hab jetzt seit...
vier oder fünf
Tagen schon,
nehme ich nur noch eine Viertel-Tablette abends.
Also ich werd
das Zeug so langsam aber sicher los,
wie es aussieht.
zwischenzeitlich habe ich ja mal eine ganze genommen mittlerweile nämlich nur
eine viertel bisher habe ich immer eine halbe genommen jetzt nämlich nur eine
viertel und es läuft wunderbar kein problem aber ich kann halt jederzeit
wenn was ist einfach ein bisschen mehr nehmen wieder aber dass das läuft
vielleicht vielleicht bald gar nichts mehr
abends morgens mein zeug werde ich weiter futtern
Das ist exzellent.
Zumindest bevor wir Setser was machen,
muss ich erst einmal meine 46 Minuten flitzen nachher.
Also ich werde jetzt was futtern.
Es gibt... Achso, Chat.
Was gibt es heute zu essen?
Ihr könnt eigentlich kaum falsch liegen.
Ah doch, ihr 50-50 Chance habt, ihr 50-50.
Nudel mit Reis, nein.
Lachsnudel, nein.
Nudel mit Lachs, nein.
Nudel mit Hackfleisch, aaaah.
Passt.
Es gibt Spaghetti Bolognese, allerdings mit veganem Hackfleisch und nicht echtem Hackfleisch.
München mit Reis.
Da geht das...
Morgen, Leute.
Morgen habe ich mir schon fest vorgenommen.
Morgen fahre ich nach Frankfurt irgendwann im Laufe des Tages.
Und...
Beste hier.
Excellent.
Äh.
Ja.
Korean Fried Chicken, Leute.
Excellent.
Das werde ich mir morgen reinhauen.
In einer etwas größeren Portion als das hier.
Warum Frankfurt am Montag?
Warum nicht?
Ist da irgendwas, was ich verpasst habe?
So ein ganz normaler Tag, oder?
Hast du nicht frei?
Doch, habe ich.
Ich habe frei.
Aber ich kann trotzdem nach Frankfurt fahren.
Ich habe ein Deutschland-Ticket.
Ja, Leute
Ah, Pommes frites, niemand nimmt das mit Pommes frites
der noch normal ist
Das ist ja hier, best fit
Korean fried chicken mit Reis
Excellent, excellent
Also von wegen Veganer
Ich futter schon auch Fleisch, aber ich versuch halt hauptsächlich
veganen Kram zu futtern.
Aber ab und zu
muss das trotzdem.
Da war ich noch nicht.
Ich glaube kaum, dass sie
Fried Chicken vegan anbieten können.
Was sollen sie machen?
Brokkoli frittieren, oder?
Also beste Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis ist da immer, man bestellt sich ein Mittagsmenü.
Da kriegt man so einen Pot Fried Chicken, ein Reis dabei und dann bestelle ich mir noch für 1,50 Euro ein extra Reis dabei.
Das ist dann immer komplett sättigend.
Zwei Schüsseln Reis und ein Fried Chicken.
Ka-u-li.
Was ist das denn?
Wings.
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Aus was ist das?
Was ist Kauli?
Blumenkohl.
Kauli-Flower.
Ah, das ist Blumenkohl.
Okay, alles besser als Brokkoli oder sowas.
Brokkoli ist...
Also, kann ich nur in ganz kleinen Dosen und auch nur gescheit gemacht essen.
Leute, es gibt Essen.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns heute Mittag, wenn ich nach dem Rennen noch Bock drauf habe.
Wird mal wieder Zeit, dass ich ein bisschen mehr strebe.
Aber letzte Woche, wie gesagt, war jetzt nicht so geil.
Ja, hat nicht so Bock zu.
Wir sehen uns.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Danke für die Subs.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Macht's gut.
See you.
Und guckt mal beim Fabian vorbei auf YouTube und guckt euch mal sein Video an.
Da freut er sich bestimmt.
Bis dann, macht's gut.
See you.